j'espère que vous allez bien bienvenue
pour ce cet épisode 2 des Brest de
spolium sur la chaîne de Gauthier Geo
spoil on vient de voir qu'on a oublié de
donner des crayons aux joueurs
ils vont chercher des crayons pas de
souci bon j'ai fait suffisamment de
musique bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur la chaîne de Gauthier au
spoil pour ce épisode 2 des Brest de
spodium j'espère que vous allez bien
on va partir sur donc la suite de la
dernière fois de l'épisode qu'il y a eu
d'il y a deux semaines si vous l'avez
pas vu je vous invite à aller le voir
sur les plateformes de Replay donc soit
sur cette chaîne twitch directement les
la VOD est toujours là soit sur Youtube
soit en replay sur Spotify si vous
préférez l'écouter en podcast
si jamais moi c'est pas Gauthier Geo
spoil moi c'est the Willow je vais être
le maître du jeu pour ce pour cette
session comme la session de la dernière
fois mais Gauthier j'ose pas il est
autour de la table en tant que joueur
pour que le voici bonjour c'est moi
Gautier je peux comment tu vas ça va ça
va très bien je suis extrêmement chaud
j'ai eu des
des comment dire j'ai entendu dire que
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui allait être
incroyable j'espère donc j'ai très très
hâte de commencer sinon
juste nul en fait
ok donc est-ce que tu peux te
représenter mais tu as fait la dernière
fois pour les gens qui passeraient sur
cet épisode 2 qui ont pas vu l'épisode 1
et qui te connaissent pas bien sûr
Gauthier
Delplace de la chaîne Geo spoil je suis
médiateur scientifique je parle plutôt
de géologie d'environnement mais voilà
on est en 2023 on se fait un pas de
porte
et puis voilà aujourd'hui je fais ça sur
twitch demain peut-être un only fat on
ne sait pas
donc si jamais vous voulez aller voir
ces réseaux sociaux il y a des commandes
dans le chat donc pour l'extamation
Gauthier point d'exclamation Frédéric le
nom de son personnage Fredo Fredo si
vous préférez si vous êtes un team
finalement et je alors je rebondis
là-dessus il y en a pour tout le monde
et en fait en dessous du live il y a un
panneau avec écrit les commandes pour
tout le monde exactement
j'ai au spoil voilà sur ma gauche on a
Valentine sens de comptoir comment tu
vas très bien et toi je me refais pas la
bonjour de bonjour
non pas cette route très bien bon pareil
du coup est-ce que tu peux te présenter
pour les gens qui passeraient par là qui
n'ont pas vu l'épisode 1 et qui te
connaissent pas bonjour Valentine
science de comptoir aujourd'hui arnoli
fans demain peut-être twitch
et sinon sur Youtube
je ne suis pas sur une fente n'allez pas
voir les contes
sur Youtube et sur Twitter et sur
Instagram et sur Tik Tok et sur Facebook
pour parler donc de géologie encore une
fois parce que quand on parle jamais
c'est ça c'était le chômage ou ça donc
voilà d'accord
les réseaux de Valentine donc pour
exclamation Valentine point
d'exclamation sciences de comptoir ou
SDC ça fait une science de comptoir si
on se comptoir c'est un peu long à
écrire pour les installation
on a
Clotilde Clotilde
est-ce que je peux te présenter ouais
alors moi je sais pas ce que c'est only
fans donc là j'ai pris 30 ans dans la
figure
mais vous m'expliquerez tout ça
non mais je crois je comprends vite fait
donc oui la chaîne passée sauvage c'est
une chaîne qui parle d'archéologie
majoritairement parce que c'est ma
formation de départ mais on fait on
parle aussi de d'anthropologie des
technologies un peu d'histoire et on
fait à la fois du bas du format
classique face caméra mais on va aussi
on fait aussi des reportages où on part
sur les chantiers de fouilles pour
expliquer le métier d'archéologue c'est
elle ma caméra
[Musique]
ok donc pareil que les deux autres il y
a des commandes dans le chat pour aller
voir ses réseaux point d'exclamation
passer sauvage on voit que ça me Sion
Clotilde ou le nom de son personnage
conversation Gloria
et le dernier moindre Arnaud de stupide
économic exactement donc c'est du
journaliste économique donc on va parler
de de plein de choses qui se passent
dans notre société actuellement dans le
passé dans le futur tout ça
et puis aujourd'hui donc je vais jouer
le personnage de Alain chicheportif
Pierre Alain je suis sportif pardon
excusez-moi thichich
pour les intimes encore une fois donc je
crois qu'il y a pas de commandes si on
fait point d'interrogation point
d'exclamation chichi ça donne rien
Pierre Alain Chicheportiche alors tout
exactement comme c'est voilà et plein
aussi
les gens se débrouillent il faut faire
confiance un petit peu à l'audience
aussi de temps en temps donc voilà et
puis aussi point d'exclamation stupides
logiquement
Arnaud
ok nickel est-ce que tu as rajouté les
points d'exclamation roll of silence
[Applaudissements]
comme ça voilà n'hésitez pas à commenter
l'émission sur Twitter insta avec le
hashtag roll of silence voilà on lance
c'est rolofc c'est très bien voilà du
coup on remercie le CNC de nous aider à
financer ce projet qui est assez cool et
le quai des savoirs qui nous aident à
coproduire en nous prêtant le Spring
studio dans lequel on se trouve donc
merci à eux pour ça vous donc pareil que
la dernière fois vous allez pouvoir
influencer sur l'histoire un flux et sur
l'histoire pardon toi d'influenceurs
via des sondages et des quiz dans le
chat donc des sondages qui vous
permettront de choisir les prochaines
choses que les héros vont rencontrer et
des quiz qui vont vous permettre si vous
répondez juste de
leur donner un bonus ou un malus selon
votre bon vouloir
à la fin de l'émission On va revenir sur
des notions abordées lors de l'épisode
vous vous pourrez nous poser des
questions dans le chat on aura le chat à
ce moment là donc n'hésitez pas si vous
avez des questions vous notez et venir
nous les poser à la fin on se fera un
plaisir d'y répondre avec grand plaisir
du coup
j'ai oublié de dire quelque chose lors
du premier épisode ce que je j'ai
complètement zappé la première fois j'ai
expliqué à tous mes joueurs avant le
début de l'émission comment ça marchait
un jeu de rôle etc les règles leur
présenter la fiche de personnage et tout
mais j'ai oublié qu'on avait aussi un
public qui fait pas forcément du jeu de
rôle du coup c'est pas compliqué en fait
il joue tous des personnages quand on
veut savoir définir si oui ou non ils
vont réussir une action parce que on
n'est pas sûr ça semble pas clair leur
idée etc on leur fait lancer un dé
leur objectif c'est de faire en dessous
de leur score donc leurs résultats od va
être un score sur 100 eux ils ont une
compétence sur 100 si leur score od est
plus bas que la compétence il réussisse
sinon ils échouent si jamais vous voulez
revérifier ça c'est marqué en dessous du
player il y a un point d'exclamation
règle si pas de bêtises ouais ouais on
peut faire un exemple aussi tu peux
faire un exemple vas-y je t'en prie je
je me saisis d'une épée et je veux
non je me saisis d'une épée et je veux
me battre contre un garde ok tu viens me
faire un jet de combat au corps à corps
pour voir si tu arrives à toucher ce
gars très bien
j'ai fait 29 sur ma compétence combat
qui était à 70 donc tu réussis voilà
c'est simplement comme ça si jamais vous
n'êtes pas sûr d'avoir compris n'hésitez
pas à faire la mon exclamation règle
dans le cadre ou à lire en dessous
un petit résumé c'est pas très compliqué
sinon demander dans le chat il y a des
gens qui le seront vous expliquer avec
grand plaisir à mon avis il y a aucun
souci puis voilà je pense qu'on est bon
pour lancer ce deuxième épisode yes on
est chaud générique en régie
nous sommes en 2223 dans la province
d'horizon lors d'une panne critique du
générateur géothermique qui alimente la
ville et ses alentours nos héros se sont
portés volontaires pour aller voir ce
qu'il s'y passe après quelques errants
souterraines ils ont fini finalement
découvert la raison de cette panne et la
scène est particulièrement sanglante
néanmoins poussé par leur volonté de
mener à bien la mission dans laquelle
ils se sont engagés ils ont décidé
d'ignorer leur peur et de régler ça au
plus vite bien décidé à retourner au
complexe Elixia pour rentrer chez eux
après quelques réparations des systèmes
sabotés ils se sont fait surprendre par
un groupe de personnes armées qui
possèdent des torches de spolium rouge
après quelques négociations habitement
menées qui leur a probablement sauvé la
vie ils se sont fait menoter et mettre
un sac sur la tête avant de se faire
embarquer dans des véhicules
le trajet est assez court mais personne
ne répond à leurs questions ni à leur
revendication ils finissent par se faire
détacher au milieu d'une cellule tous
les quatre démunis de leurs affaires
sans information c'est sur ceux qui
veulent arriver et surtout avec un
gigantesque mal de ventre pour trois
d'entre eux qui ne se sentent vraiment
pas bien
donc pour rappel dans le premier épisode
vous les viewers là sur le chat vous
leur avez fait manger un repas périmé
sauf Pierre-Alain qui a pas voulu goûter
donc là vous êtes dans une cellule A4
seul vous n'avez plus vos affaires et
vous êtes vraiment malade
alors d'habitude moi je dis problème
solution là je vous avoue je vois
surtout du problème est-ce que vous avez
votre montre ou pas
qu'est-ce que vous voulez je veux pas
appeler quelqu'un avec une montre en
plus
j'ai personne dans mes contacts
une corde des barres de fer une corde à
valise
et légèrement barbouillé on ne se voit
pas en fait
j'imagine non
est-ce que il y aura un garde
s'il vous plaît aucune réponse c'est
urgent
s'il vous plaît
moi aussi s'il vous plaît
venez ici tout de suite est-ce que tu
m'entends eh oh
[Musique]
personne ne répond pour l'instant alors
les cellules les petites quand même moi
ça m'inquiète un petit peu parce que là
s'il y a quelqu'un qui commence à
faire
j'ai pas trop peur je me dis c'était un
peu les Aigles rouges dont nous parler
scientifique dedans on ne sait pas
en quoi c'est positif on sait pas qui
sont partis les aider vous souvenez
quand vous a dit allez réparer le
générateur je vais les Aigles rouges
je sais pas sorte de milice d'ultra
gauche ou quoi
tout va à
[Musique]
volote
qu'est-ce que vous voulez réfléchir on
est dans une cellule et moi je veux
faire le tour moi je fais le tour voilà
l'ouvrir c'est des grandes barres de fer
je suis
il y a pas de lit est-ce que le sol est
en train parce que là on peut pas on
peut pas creuser par exemple pour faire
nos propres canalisations non ça va être
compliqué on peut pas s'enfuir et les
chiottes ça te dit quelque chose là où
tu étais déjà venu ici
et oui ça me dit vaguement quelque chose
oui
quoi n'importe quoi
j'ai des chiottes je vois que des
chiottes et oui j'ai envie de j'ai envie
de caguer quoi
on peut peut-être délimiter une zone par
exemple
très bien au bout d'un petit moment il y
a vous emmener des bruits de sport qui
s'approche de votre cellule et d'un seul
coup devant les barreaux un visage
amical que vous reconnaissez Gaston oh
Gaston
les
amis mes amis merci beaucoup pour ce que
vous avez fait au générateur
oui bien sûr oui bah en fait visiblement
ce qui s'est passé est assez terrible de
ce qu'on m'a dit et vous avez été
retrouvé au milieu de là donc je suis
allé défendre votre cause auprès des
ailes rouges donc ne vous en faites pas
vous allez être libéré vous allez bien
avoir une discussion avec le général et
des toilettes et des toilettes
je suppose que oui
de la cellule non
autorisé à venir discuter avec vous
rapidement avant qu'on vous je vous
explique vous allez devoir rendre des
services rendre des comptes en fait au
général
moi de mon côté j'ai avancé sur ma
théorie des voyages temporels pour vous
renvoyer chez vous très bien je pense
que j'en aurai pour une semaine
avant cette semaine
[Musique]
tout de suite
et je vous le ferai savoir dès que vous
pouvez rentrer chez vous
si on peut aider n'hésitez pas oui oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en attente
désespéré aller vite me chercher le
général qu'on finisse j'ai repéré le
trou là au fond de la cellule
quelques minutes après il y a une femme
qui vient vous ouvrir
qui vous libère et qui vous dit veuillez
me suivre s'il vous plaît est-ce que on
peut passer aux toilettes si vous plaît
oui s'il vous plaît pourquoi
c'est important là qu'ils aient voilà
merci merci
vous pouvez vous soulager rapidement
ah ça va mieux
bon je suis Madame je tire la chasse
[Musique]
donc succès à te promener dans les
couloirs du coup où tu vois enfin vous
voyez d'autres cellules avec certaines
qui sont vides d'autres où il y a des
personnes enfermées
et toi en fait tu reconnais tu sais où
tu es tu es dans le complexe c'est vrai
je suis déjà venu par ici si tu
travailles en fait oui mais je il est
grand le complexe mais je suis pas venu
souvent ici quand même ça te semble
bizarre qu'il y a des cellules ben oui
je reconnais un peu je pense qu'on est
dans une aile ou que je connais mais
dites moi ma bonne dame pourquoi il y a
des cellules on est où exactement là au
QG des aigles rouges mais là on est à
élixir là
oui c'est l'ancien secteur 1 le secteur
le secteur il y a pas des cellules dans
le secteur
vous voyez bien que si
et elles sont là depuis pourquoi il y a
des cellules si vous voulez moi je peux
je pense je peux vous expliquer c'est
que entre 200 ans et maintenant ils ont
construit des cellules élixir mais
c'est vraiment l'interprétation
[Musique]
les organismes avec des cellules on est
multicellules et à ce moment-là ça nous
permet de nous développer parce que le
pH à l'intérieur d'une cellule il est
différent que celui à l'extérieur et
comme ça ça peut faire des réactions
chimiques authentique à l'intérieur de
la cellule et comme ça en général
[Musique]
à la base et est-ce que aigle rouge
c'est un rapport avec l'aiglefin
est-ce que excusez-moi ma charlotine
mais pour construire une prison faut de
l'argent ça coûte cher emprisonner les
gens moi je croyais qu'on était dans un
endroit il y avait pas d'argent en fait
qui c'est ça la question c'est des
aigles rouges c'est quoi on débarque
elle part elle vous demande de vous
laisser vous suivre que vous la suiviez
pardon
[Musique]
elle vous appelle jusqu'à un bureau elle
vous ouvre la porte elle ferme derrière
vous et vous vous retrouvez devant une
personne genre un homme un peu âgé les
cheveux courts
militaires vraiment qui a un bureau et
qui vous dit asseyez-vous
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur tantôt
je fais ça
bonjour monsieur le général j'imagine
effectivement Georges Beaulieu
que je sache un peu à qui j'ai à faire
je commence allez je suis Gloria
couperose je suis archéologue directrice
de du chantier archéologique de de à
côté d'élixia
mais bon c'était un paquet d'années
visiblement
[Musique]
voilà je me retrouve là avec mes
compagnons
perdus
d'accord les autres
présidents de la CCI un d'élixia dans le
même cadre que que Madame Lauriane pros
je me retrouve ici à accomplir des
actions héroïques alors
je ne comprends pas vraiment ce que je
fais ici pour tout vous dire ce que je
veux moi vraiment c'est retourner chez
moi que ce soit bien clair maintenant si
les forces armées d'élixia et de toute
la région peuvent me ramener chez moi je
vous dis allez-y et je suis au
garde-à-vous
très bien quant à moi je suis et enfin
je vous ferai pas la prendre me
présenter parce que vous avez sans doute
vu me voir dû me voir dans
meilleur de vue
dans la Gazette d'horizon vous voyez ce
qui mange j'ai fait la Une c'était en
le 24 janvier 2023 ah oui non c'était un
autre oui bon alors je suis gentille
bidon je suis la
bidon je suis serial entrepreneuse d'une
seule start-up qui s'appelle Flappy
c'est la french litthologie
et donc on a découvert un super gisement
de pétrole qui apparemment est allé
jusqu'au bout est-ce qu'on a cru voir
dans des bidons récemment
et donc moi aussi j'aimerais bien
repartir
j'ai fondé Flappy
donc moi c'est Fredo je suis concierge
j'étais concierge alixia peut-être que
votre contrat
il y a une élection tout ça j'étais pas
je vais me présenter à mon tour Georges
Beaulieu comme je vous ai dit le général
des aigles rouges là les forces armées
de horizon
enfin on dirait plutôt milice vu
l'organisation on essaie de faire en
sorte que d'organiser horizon de manière
à ce que il n'y ait pas de débordement
et qu'on essaie de suivre un chemin qui
a pour but de restaurer l'humanité
autant que possible
alors ça implique forcément des
sacrifices ça implique d'être dur d'être
ferme mais on est persuadé que notre
objectif est noble
ici on travaille tous mains dans la main
dans le but
[Musique]
de restaurer la gloire de l'humanité
d'autres fois
[Musique]
mais la gloire avec des aigles donc
oui très bien ça vous rappelle des
choses
oui on verra plus tard
monsieur le président général
j'ai une question on a croisé des petits
des petits malfrats quand même qui qui
ont menacé de nous envoyer des balles ou
je pense là on n'avait pas déjà tout et
du coup on s'est posé des questions
quand même est-ce que vous les
connaissez par rapport à ça
donc oui moi je sais qui c'est enfin
j'aimerais savoir plus précisément qui
c'est mais je connais leur groupe et
j'essaie de faire en sorte qu'ils
arrêtent de nuire mais Gaston a beau me
dire que vous êtes
[Musique]
et donc je collecte des objets parce que
je j'adore ça déjà c'est ma passion ça
m'intéresse et oui c'est vrai j'avoue
j'ai voulu ramener un objet du futur
pour pour l'étudier voilà l'archéologie
inversée
je me disais que ça allait plaire au
labo créa riz
centre de recherche archéologique
anthropologique
vous avez déjà fait de l'archéologie
monsieur
on n'aime pas ça que les squelettes
c'est plutôt notre Palace tes parents
encore des squelettes mais c'était un
squelette en devenir et nous sommes tous
des squelettes je pense que là on est
vraiment sur le trait de la ligne
c'était vraiment
dans un cadre purement comment dire de
de partage de connaissance d'études en
général on les rend enfin
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec les
archéologues tout ça là bon bizarre
d'accord vraiment il ramène des objets
c'est oui moi j'ai déjà vu ça elle est
pas le je comprends pas plus que vous je
trouve c'est voilà à la limite du
respect bon apparemment c'est de la
science bah voilà je le sors mais j'ai
de la dans la cellule il y avait un
petit caillou et j'ai mis dans ma poche
et puis voilà je vous le rends là
j'ai plus rien donc cette manette vous
appartient
non enfin si mais je suis une vieille
dame j'ai beaucoup vécu et je pouvais
plus porter la mallette on a marché on a
marché donc cher églantine s'est proposé
et elle l'a porté merci encore je vous
embrasse les solidaires et on se sentait
je vous fais pas confiance mais je fais
confiance à Gaston
je vais vous garder à l'oeil
le moindre écart c'est fini c'est pas
prévu après nous n'avons pas prévu de
faire des écarts ce qu'on a demandé
depuis le début nous c'était d'être mis
dans une petite pièce avec voilà comme
ça et d'attendre qu'on nous renvoie chez
nous
générateur donc déjà je trouve ça à la
limite de l'abus parce que là c'est vrai
que bon j'ai l'habitude d'être
entreprenant mais là c'était beaucoup
demandé quand même c'est du travail non
rémunéré en plus
quel cadre légal
moi je me les colle-t-il depuis qu'on
est arrivé ici bon je peux vous dire
mettez-nous
mettez-nous au trou fait
nous tout ce qu'on veut c'est rentrer
chez nous
ici autour de cette table qui n'existe
pas
on est on n'est pas assez souple pour
faire un grand écart de toute façon moi
sans doute mais je peux vous le dire
parce que du coup ça va pas dans le sens
mais donc vous inquiétez pas on fera pas
des cas mais la meilleure enfin pour
vous débarrasser vous de nous et
ramenez-nous chez nous voilà voilà
j'ai pas envie de vous garder dans une
cellule pendant une semaine
je suis d'accord pour vous envoyer chez
vous si effectivement vous êtes innocent
actuellement je vous fais pas confiance
du coup je vais vous demander un petit
service en échange juste pour savoir que
vous êtes de bonne foi et si vous êtes
de bonne foi il n'y aura aucun problème
pour vous retourner chez vous
alors si vous êtes en train de parler de
technique de torture un peu moyenâgeuse
en mode vous êtes coupable vous êtes
innocent en fonction de
service je suis parti il a dit
Monsieur général bon écoutez je pense
que vous avez déjà vu un peu le monde
dans lequel vous êtes arrivés c'est bien
pour ça qu'on veut rentrer
justement
comme je vous ai dit de restaurer
l'humanité telle qu'elle était avant
donc on veut faire en sorte de étendre
la production de spodium le plus
possible ah oui
expansdre notre
influence sur les provinces alentours de
manière à pouvoir distribuer ce podium
le plus pour que les gens puissent
s'éclairer et continuer à vivre un peu
comme avant
restaurer les anciens systèmes de
communication qui passaient par câble et
non pas par satellite qui actuellement
sont tous brouillés ce qui fait qu'on
est tous un peu bloqué sans pouvoir
communiquer avec nos voisins très bien
de manière à pouvoir vivre dans ce monde
obscur
et sombre
je suis pas une lumière mais je vous
explique moi le service que je vais vous
demander
c'est de nous aider dans ce but de
restaurer l'humanité dans la de laquelle
vous venez donc je pense que personne
d'autre que vous ne la connais mieux que
vous pour donner que nous ne sommes pas
nés là-bas c'est vrai ça je crois que
l'avantage comparatif là
et peut-être que du coup vous pourriez
nous apporter quelques clés qui nous
aideraient dans notre quête
[Musique]
dans ce but
si vous faites ça pour moi je
considérais que vous êtes clean les
Aigles rouges ont besoin de remettre la
main sur la production de pollium
vous voulez qu'on vous aide
on ne produit pas spodium
c'est un peu pour notre objectif on a
besoin de produire du spodium j'ai
besoin que vous médiiez ou que vous
aidiez les scientifiques je ne sais pas
n'importe quoi trouvez-nous un moyen
quoi d'avoir accès à du spodium en
grande quantité oui alors par contre
alors nous quand d'où vient ça existait
pas le spolium donc là il y a peut-être
un mauvais choix de candidature
ce que vous voulez comme vous aide mais
là pour le coup le spolium n'y connaît
pas grand chose quoi
je pense que vous y connaissez quelque
chose à n'importe quel autre ressource
[Musique]
pour nous occuper c'est vrai que on peut
rendre un service si ça peut vous
raconter comment c'était mais ça va vous
le blues
en 73
Ibiza 73 unités
est-ce qu'on pourrait éventuellement
avoir un briefing par quelqu'un qui
connaît exactement le spodium tout ça
enfin voilà d'avoir une idée alors moi
je m'y connais pas et ça va pas vraiment
être mon rôle en fait ce que je veux que
vous fassiez c'est que vous me dit votre
enquête de votre côté moi j'ai déjà des
personnes qui travaillent sur le sujet
mais je me dis que peut-être que votre
regard sur le monde et bien différent
d'une autre et peut-être que vous
trouverez des moyens différents pour y
arriver plus facilement que nous
écoutez moi j'ai envie de vous dire j'ai
développé Alexia une fois et puis toute
la province d'horizon pour toute la
ville d'horizon c'est un challenge que
j'accepte avec avec beaucoup de
d'humilité et dualité bien sûr je pense
que nous pourrons et effectivement faire
croître
cette alors ville je sais pas si on
appelle ça une ville encore je sais pas
comment vous appelez voilà votre
baraquement mais nous pouvons faire de
tout ça quelque chose de grand et
vraiment développer les liens entre les
prix partenaires économiques
donc oui oui on est ravi de vous aider
donc ça c'est notre option numéro une
c'est ce sur quoi les Aigles rouges se
concentrent le plus possible l'option
numéro 2 qui nous permettrait de
restaurer l'humanité je vous le dis
juste à titre informatif c'est
travailler sur la suppression des
particules noires ça c'est les
scientifiques à Xia qui le font c'est
pour ça qu'ils ne sont pas sous notre
contrôle plus on travaille en partenaire
avec eux on leur fournit de
l'électricité de la nourriture de l'eau
et vivre finalement il se débrouille ils
sont ils sautent au gèrent et ils ne
nous rendent pas de compte mais on sait
qu'il travaille sur ce sujet
l'option numéro 3 je pense qu'elle vient
de mettre niveau sur un plateau d'argent
mais ce sera à vous de me le prouver si
par miracle on est capable de trouver
l'origine de ça et vous rentrez chez
vous vous pourrez peut-être empêcher que
tout ça arrive
oui on fera alors au maximum mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut savoir qui est le
coupable du ce que j'ai vu un film comme
ça où il fallait revenir dans le passé
[Musique]
très bien et bien allons-y allons
développer économiquement toute la
province on va vous rendre aux affaires
juste à côté on va vous rendre un peu
tout ce que vous avez est-ce qu'on peut
avoir des affaires en plus peut-être
enfin je veux dire c'est une mission
quand même galère
un poudrier
ok bon vous sortez de la salle
si vous demandez rien vous demandez
plein de spolium
moi je peux lancer des fouilles
d'abord on écoute le briefing on verra
ce qu'il faut mais là on a le général
devant nous alors je n'ai pas compris
qu'on allait nous rebriffer je vous
avais dit que vous aviez des mines de
spolium et là vous nous dites il faut
trouver du spolium
et pourquoi vous synthétisez plus
j'aimerais bien savoir mais moi je suis
pas alcientifique ni ah donc il faut
juste qu'on aille demander aux
scientifiques os j'en sais rien genre
actuellement
il doit savoir trouver un moyen vous
nous laissez Gaston parce que sinon ça
va se mettre
si vous voulez le déranger c'est vous
qui rentrez plus tard
comment il s'appelle ce jeune
Adrien Durand
Victor Victor Victor oui Victor c'est de
choper Victor
très bien en fait vous avez besoin de
rien du coup c'est bon
moi je suis pas scientifique
Elixia si vous êtes dans le secteur 1
oui on retourne au 3S on va voir vite le
métro est fermé et en fait on te refuse
l'accès vers les anciens couloirs refuse
je connais tu parles à la personne qui
te refuse l'accès mais écoutez je les
connais les couloirs je vais pas me
perdre pourquoi vous voulez pas que je
passe parce que c'est protégé vous
n'avez pas les accréditations requises
pour entrer dans ces pièces mais je veux
juste aller au 3S Beaulieu nous a donné
un droit
le général Beaulieu nous a expressément
demandé de prendre ce couloir là
maintenant pour traverser et aller
directement au 3S donc le général
Beaulieu vous a dit de traverser le son
2 qui a été dévastée
[Musique]
ils sont un peu un peu pert urbés il
nous a dit de faire le tour on le fait
par ce couloir là c'est ça l'extérieur
c'est l'extérieur par où c'est éclairé
là
rouge
mais on retourne voir général Beaugrand
là
beau droit
vous voyez une personne qui est en train
de travailler sur un grand bureau en
train de dessiner quelque chose
est-ce que vous vous y arrêtez vous
passez votre jeu rien à non si
moi j'adore
en fait il est en train de faire une
carte
moi je c'est on peut on peut regarder
monsieur oui bien sûr c'est une carte
c'est le complexe c'est la nouvelle la
nouvelle carte de la province horizon je
suis en train de travailler dessus
une carte géologique ah non c'est pas
une mine déjà
et c'est il y a des copies de cette
carte celle-là pas encore du coup je
suis en train de travailler dessus c'est
quoi votre nom Saïd
Monsieur Saïd
vous êtes cartographe oui
donc j'imagine que vous connaissez une
bonne situation
un peu mes connaissances et je rajoute
est-ce que vous savez
forcément j'ai une un appareil photo sur
ma montre
ultra connectée vraiment pas très avancé
pour l'instant non mais au début de son
travail donc c'est un gros gros clip
pour l'instant juste vous voyez que ça
ressemble à une carte je prends quand
même je passe il faut garder
quoi vous êtes dans une carte vous a
écouté si vous avez des cartes moi j'en
ai pas mais en fait je l'ai fait ensuite
je les donne à la mairie et il les
imprime et les distribués en
libre-service
donc on a juste aller à la mairie si
vous êtes dans une carte Vous demandez à
la mairie on vous donne une carte
est-ce que vous auriez une carte pour
aller dans le noir si vous voulez
attendre des militaires quoi est-ce que
vous avez une carte pour nous mener
jusqu'à la mairie
vous n'êtes pas du coin
malheureusement on vous expliquera ça
plus tard oui vous explique où est la
mairie vous le saviez
en fait d'accord
le bâtiment un peu changé donc on se dit
peut-être la mairie a bougé quoi
d'accord
les rues d'horizon sont assez bien
éclairées en spolium ah donc c'est bleu
la plupart des endroits sauf que il y a
certains points où vous voyez du rouge
et en fait c'est juste pour montrer les
points où c'est chez les Aigles rouges
le secteur 1 d'élixia donc le QG des
aigles rouges c'est bien éclairé en
rouge il y a des points qui sont en
rouge très bien
donc vous vous rendez vers la mairie
vous la trouvez sans trop de problèmes
elle a pas bougé vous voyez que il y a
des bâtiments qui sont toujours bien
entretenus d'autres beaucoup plus
délabrés donc en fait ça dépend genre
vous rendez compte qu'en fait il y a des
points qui ont été priorisés par rapport
à d'autres dans qu'on a sauvegarde de la
ville et puis il y a pas mal de
personnes qui travaillent à la
restauration ils sont en train de
reconstruire des bâtiments sur des sur
des bâtiments détruits
la mairie elle a pas changé vous la
reconnaissez complètement
il y a toujours
une femme à l'accueil qui vous accueille
je vous dis bienvenue qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour vous
bonjour je vais donc nous sommes venus
récupérer une carte Monsieur
Saïd ou nous a nous a dit que vous aviez
des Descartes ici si on pouvait avoir un
exemplaire s'il vous plaît tout à fait
un seul ou vous aurez un cheval
si vraiment la feuille de papier est une
ressource très rare dans votre
Bourgogne
du coin
toujours aussi magnifique
[Musique]
ah oui on voit bien la montagne
d'accord merci beaucoup
vous qui êtes du coin surtout tout à
Pierre-Alain qui connaît bien la région
tu connais bien
en fait tu
mon horizon il y a pas de problème
edithia aucun souci
il y a les noms
en fait tu reconnais un seul nom c'est
j'ai oublié comment il s'appelle
celui-là tu peux me dire
miratria tu connais le reste tu connais
pas
donc il y a des nouvelles villes
elle date de quand
[Musique]
déjà
la mairie était ouverte on va pas patron
demander il était 17h donc on a eu la
chance mais vous êtes en après-midi
d'ailleurs si jamais
est-ce que c'est encore pertinent enfin
je veux dire
il fait tout noir arrêtez de vous moquer
et puis
je suis désolé
[Musique]
mais on va avoir victoire
et puis ils nous font un powerpoint de
ce qu'il faut faire
Gaston il faut qu'il travaille un nous
ramener à mes hommes oui d'accord on le
dérange pas
comment alors
le spolium là les scientificaux cela
vous allez lui demander comment qu'on le
fait vous allez le faire
quelques slides ce serait du meilleur
restaurant peut-être on va commencer par
aller le voir oui allez on y va ok
retourne complexe pour tourner vers le
complexe
toi c'est un chemin que tu faisais
régulièrement oui genre ça t'est arrivé
parfois tu pourrais les transports en
commun mais parfois tu préfères les
marchés pour aller à ton taf et tu es un
peu nostalgique
tu te dis on va voir ce que c'est
devenu ma maison
vous allez au complexe
vous suivez le petit chemin en fait qui
longe le complexe donc vous voyez
effectivement le secteur 2 qui a été
complètement
ravagé qui a été repris par les plantes
en fait il y avait une espèce d'énorme
d'hommes de plantes c'est impraticable à
l'intérieur toi tu sais pourquoi c'était
le secteur qui s'axé sur les recherches
botaniques
ils font des trucs et après quand il se
barre en vacances ceci a pas Fredo pour
enfin bref voilà classique
vous arrivez du coup au secteur 3 il y a
une porte d'entrée de fortune qui a été
créée sur le côté sur le flanc en fait
vous rentrez
vous êtes dans
très bien moi je connais bien je me
souviens où est-ce que on avait discuté
avec Gaston et Victor
ok donc je guide un peu tout le monde
vers la dernière fois où on les a vu
quoi c'était pas loin de la cantine ok
[Musique]
je parle pas que du ragoût
c'est là où on a disparu
allons-y vous y allez donc oui tu
retrouves ton chemin vous croisez des
scientifiques qui vous regardent un peu
bizarre quand même ce qui vous
connaissent pas
vous voyez une scientifique aussi si par
terre je suis content
vous arrivez donc dans la au niveau de
la salle à 4S c'était là vous avez
disparu il y a Victor qui est devant la
salle
bonjour Victor
Monsieur Victor nous avons nous venons
de rencontrer le général Beaulieu tout à
fait Gaston m'avait dit que ça allait
arriver d'accord c'est bien passé
peu importe donc
[Musique]
avec une mission mon cher Victor
d'accord une mission de la plus haute
importance
nous devons
trouver
et trouver et sauver c'est une mission
de deux étapes trouver sauver donc nous
aimerions avoir s'il vous plaît
un compte-rendu de la situation
nous allons essayer de vous sauver mais
pour ça on a besoin d'informations
si je dis pas de bêtises mais c'est pas
moi qui gère ça je sais pas c'est
une production quand même est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez pensé à leur
demander
leur demander quoi
discuter avec les autres un gros
problème il y a quelques années si je
dis pas de bêtises
de ce qu'on m'a expliqué
on avait des données sur la production
spodium et un jour on s'est rendu compte
qu'elle était complètement sabotés
et impossible de se retrouver comment on
fait du soleil
donc là le village où vous l'achetez ils
en font plus en fait si mais pourquoi
vous l'achetez plus nous on l'achète
le secret et des spions vous espionner
on essaie de régler le problème
votre problème
c'est notre problème
est-ce que tu sais qui on peut aller
voir pour je te tutoie on a le même âge
pratiquement
tu sais qui on pourra aller voir
qui on pourra aller voir pour pour
trouver
le village comment il s'appelle le
village
c'est qui le gestionnaire gestionnaire
de quoi un problème responsable des
achats
il y a bien un service il y a bien un
service financier
non ah bah eux aussi moi je me souviens
c'était Catherine la directrice
pour rechercher le matos
[Musique]
on va voir Augustin ça a l'air d'être
lui responsable des achats
je vais lui parler moi je j'ai
l'habitude de ma machine à café les
comptables les gestionnaires
je comprends un peu quoi comment ça
fonctionne donc je vais voir
la porte
te dit pas maintenant
c'est ça prendra juste deux minutes
c'est le général Beaulieu qui nous
envoie
quand quelqu'un qui se lève qui vient
vous ouvrir tu me dis vous êtes qui
alors nous sommes des envoyés du général
Beaulieu d'accord
d'où vous achetez votre spolium
nous on achète rien si si
[Musique]
vous achetiez le spolium un village de
la région dans ce cas nous qui achetions
nous on se fait livrer par les Aigles
rouges c'est les Aigles rouges qui vous
fournissent le spoiler après nous on
sait pas où je te fournisseur
il nous dit mais il commence même pas
par nous bon bah besoin du formulaire
alors
des formulaires ils en ont hein c'est
compliqué il va falloir qu'on soit malin
d'ici mais sinon je peux vous montrer là
où ça a été saboté parce que ça a été
laissé en vrac ah bah oui oui
on y va on y va on va voir on va voir si
vous amène vers le stockage du secteur 3
je voulais dire quoi Gloria avant
j'ai pas vu le téléphone
plus tard
j'ai l'impression que vous vouliez me
dire quelque chose
je pense qu'on peut en discuter dans la
prochaine pièce
il vous amène
jusqu'à une salle de stockage du secteur
3 donc tu connais
il te montre il vous dit bon bah voilà
bah là vous voyez il y a des trucs qui
ont été un peu il y a des papiers qui
ont été volés de ce qu'on m'a dit et
d'autres qui ont été détruits mais je
peux je peux pas vous aider plus que ça
c'est par là que vous faisiez le spolium
jadis quoi bon non c'est là qu'on avait
les infos c'était d'accord est-ce qu'on
peut lire ses papiers est-ce que Madame
couperose pourrait lire sur papier je
suis désolé je vais vouloir vous laisser
là
comment ça chercher avec un jet de fin
moi je moi je cherche la pièce quoi
est-ce qu'on trouve ok on vous fouillez
bien alors il y a un placard bien marqué
spoilum
ça pourrait être le début
généralement oui quand j'essaye d'ouvrir
quelque chose
tu remarques un peu bizarre sur une sur
quelque chose en fait il y a plein
d'armoires il y a des tables aussi sur
une table il y a une enveloppe c'est
bien mise en évidence
où il y a marqué PAC
vous ouvrez le placard de ce podium pack
plein d'action centenaire
des miettes dedans et d'autres dossiers
je me dirige vers la lettre sans de rien
enfin comme ça j'ai remarqué du coin de
l'oeil du coup j'imagine je suis le seul
à l'avoir remarqué donc je me dirige
vers la lettre et je la saisie puis de
l'autre main je l'ouvre d'accord je vais
te donner juste après qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dans cette lettre vous vous avez un
truc synthèse de podium avec plein de
papiers de dessus et il y a marqué des
choses dessus
oui oui oui
vous allez vous pouvoir vous mettre par
deux un peu pour le faire
chez vous vous voyez un peu la gueule
que ça je rends normalement en régie on
est en train de vous montrer là c'est
une photo que j'ai pris du ouf du truc
en vrac
s'ils arrivent à résoudre ça on vous
montrera également le le final j'ai
envie de dire résolu attends attends
tu trouves ce papier oui
chienne
je vais t'inviter à le lire à haute voix
pour les gens qui nous écoutent et qui
ne peuvent pas le voir mais les autres
personnages n'entendent pas ça d'accord
c'est uniquement de ton ta voix
rien j'ai réussi j'ai pu créer une
brèche dans l'espace-temps qui m'a
permis de voir le passé le temps d'un
instant il faut que je garde cette
trouvaille secrète sinon les
scientifiques du coin vont vouloir s'en
servir pour leurs intérêts j'ai un
meilleur plan j'ai entendu parler d'un
ancien laboratoire souterrain je vais
m'y installer pour finir mes recherches
et contacter la pierre à l'un
Chicheportiche d'ailleurs je vais lui
laisser ces quelques notes si tu lis ces
mots je suis ta descendantes
retrouve-moi dans ce laboratoire secret
tu vas devoir te débrouiller seul pour
le trouver malheureusement
ça c'est tu as lu ça dans ton coin tu le
gardes bien bien au chaud tu peux leur
partager si tu le souhaites évidemment
mais je n'ai pas obligé c'est à toi de
voir c'est à toi de choisir
bon là
compliqué cette histoire on a des
éléments chimiques
[Musique]
attendez je vois écrit quel site là
c'est assez impressionnant on a une
liste d'éléments vous avez déjà fini
me parlait de roche tout ça ça c'est de
la classique ça d'accord acide
merci mon Seigneur
un peu réfléchir là dessus et après vous
vous allez le faire un peu en fil rouge
petit à petit pendant qu'on continue
maintenant les gens ne peuvent pas voir
dans les gens on a le même
mais vous avez le même c'est juste que
sinon vous pouvez pas vous
aideront je vous donnerai des indices
plus tard parce que il y a mais non il y
a un petit piège
que vous arrivez à trouver ok qu'est-ce
que vous voulez faire
un dernier petit coup d'oeil dans la
salle voir s'il y a pas tu trouves rien
de spécial arrête de spécial
bon alors là je pense qu'on a trouvé une
espèce de formule quand même ça
ressemble à une recette
une recette complet
[Musique]
moi je suis pas chimiste
il y en a dans la caboche
[Musique]
3 plus 2 c'est
7 h 62 +
c2h6o + quelque chose de mystérieux
parce qu'il manque une case plus 10 N =
c'est pour vous cette ligne
vous pouvez le voir vous-même sur votre
écran
j'imagine plus cette eau de
on n'a pas réussi à faire le plus
explications de chaque chose qu'est-ce
qu'on peut répéter en disant chaque
est-ce que ce serait pas la formule du
spolium
cette information
donc on est dans un complexe militaire
au scientifique où il y a une étagère
qui n'est pas fermé
que nous avons ouvert sans faire usage
de la force nous avons trouvé l'info
qu'il cherche
200 ans plus tard ça c'est des choses
c'est une chanson
et nous avons pu reconstituer un puzzle
en 5 minutes c'est parce que je suis
extrêmement intelligente
est-ce que c'est pas un piège là
[Musique]
je pense on devrait aller revoir le
général lui dire bon on a appris qu'il y
avait village qui fabrique tout ça oui
déjà enfin je veux dire si ça avait pas
ça enfin je veux dire là c'est ça va
être déjà être pour eux mais peut-être
qu'en fait c'est le développement des
sociétés enfin il y a peut-être eu un
recul un petit peu voilà
il était même pas capable de nous dire
ah oui au fait on l'achète au village de
la
je pense que les Aigles rouges n'ont pas
réussi à mettre la main sur ce village
il a il a dirige pas encore mais si il
continue à acheter ils achètent oui
c'est une menace
ils ont envahi le village non c'est vrai
que
ça se trouve là on est en train de se
faire embobiner
heureusement que c'est votre métier de
reconstituer des céramiques
c'est vrai que on a on a cette torche on
peut peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut aller voir le village
moi j'aime allez il faut savoir lequel
il faut qu'on retourne voir général on a
des armes on peut aller voir le général
et on lui demande s'il a les différents
ingrédients
je sais pas douter qu'on le remet en
question
c'est un peu louche c'était facile mais
oui
c'est vrai et les types ils sont dans le
noir depuis on sait pas combien de temps
en plus ce Victor il nous a amené un
monsieur là que on faisait baigne
personne ne nous surveille là
il faut qu'on parte mais il voudrait
nous nous piéger pourquoi
nous échangez
rapidement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire c'est quoi
notre plan d'action est-ce qu'on va à
l'office du tourisme
la mairie bon enfin au fil du tourisme
non mais au moins on va pouvoir avoir
peut-être une idée de quel village leur
vend quelque chose enfin je veux dire
les gens sont pas quand même dans leur
bulle à ce point-là ici là c'est juste
on parle que aux scientifiques on va
aller voir
un petit coup dehors les terrasses les
terrasses sont éclairées
et chauffer j'ai remarqué il y a
peut-être des bribes de conversation
et je parie qu'on peut y boire de
l'éthanol du coup ça recoupe un peu nos
enquêtes et voilà non Fredo vous avez
pas trop envie
ce texte là je suis d'accord avec Pierre
Alain c'est ça m'inspire pas confiance
on retourne dans le village et on pose
des questions aux gens un petit peu au
hasard comme ça petite boisson je dis
pas non là ça fait près tout ce qui nous
est arrivé on repart sans rien dire à
personne hein on est parti tout seul
vous sortez de la salle de stockage et
vous recroiser la femme que vous aviez
vu assise quand vous êtes rentrés et
elle fixe une bague
quand vous êtes rentré vous êtes passés
je vous ai dit il y a quelqu'un qui a
une scientifique qui est assise par
terre
je me suis dit il y a toujours des
hippies en 2223
fixé une très belle bague dorée avec un
vous êtes obligé
si je m'arrête et puis je m'arrête à son
niveau j'ai bonjour bonjour
comme ça je suis pas priorité je vous
remercie
allez très belle elle vient d'où c'est
pour mon mariage ouais on félicitations
il s'appelle comment elle s'appelle
comment pardon
félicitations pourquoi ça fait longtemps
que vous dites
elle vous a quitté
en tête de se dire que ce qu'on faisait
ici à Elixia si on avait aucune utilité
et que on serait bien plus utile à Gaïa
mais de qu'est-ce que vous faites ici
ce que j'ai compris de ce qu'elle m'a
dit c'est de trouver des
nouvelles inventions pour apprendre à
vivre dans ce monde plutôt que d'essayer
de le changer et pourquoi vous n'avez
pas voulu la suivre
c'était une grande décision mais
maintenant je commence à douter
pourquoi vous
doutez je me dis que cette raison c'est
difficile de partir d'ici c'est quand
même toute ma vie
mais rien ne vous stoppe
physiquement non
vous êtes sûr
pas que je sache en tout cas elle est la
plus partie et maintenant
j'aime plus aucun moyen de communiquer
avec elle
par parfois une lettre et
vous pour dire quoi elle devait vraiment
y croire pour partir
c'est triste pour vous abandonner comme
ça enfin pardon de remuer le couteau
dans la plaie
je dis rien moi je vous laisse parler
on va justement à Marylise
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on lui passe
un message à cet élève vous avez une
dédicace
peut-être vous voulez nous accompagner
avec nous oui
avec quelqu'un ou je ne sais pas comment
il s'appelle
si vous allez là-bas
faites-le savoir que j'ai envie de la
rejoindre comment vous appelez
a envie de rejoindre est-ce que vous
avez un moyen de nous faire
prouver que c'est bien vous qui envoyez
ce message
avec un objet précieux qu'on pourra lui
passer par exemple
qui on a une très grande mallette on est
l'équipe de sauvetage
oui bien sûr il y a le hall school dièse
je sais pas j'ai pas mal j'ai oublié
d'inventer un nombre à ce truc
c'est ils font bar restaurant
peut-être elle t'indique le chemin pour
y aller vous voulez venir avec nous
sinon je vais rester ici
par terre
bon courage on transmettre à votre
message et là je lui prends la main
comme ça on signe de
ok
vous baladez dans la ville et en fait
vous vous rendez compte que quand même
vous la connaissez bien dans cette ville
ah bah oui mais ça vous fait bizarre de
la voir changer comme ça mais vous avez
quand même tous des attaches à cette
ville une manière ou d'une autre j'ai
mon nom dans la ville enfin mon nom
qu'elle a pointé vers le bas il passe
pas loin de la maison de ma maison
10 minutes de détour si tu veux passer
je leur dis je passe devant et en fait
je me suis pas ah bon oui moi
on va passer par là c'est mieux d'accord
ok bon
et j'en profite je fais le détour j'ai
envie de passer voir parce que bon je
caresse l'espoir fou ça voilà là tu
retrouves le quartier résidentiel dans
le quel tu vivais il y a plein de
petites maisons qui sont toujours
habitées
etc qui sont en train de vivre
tranquille qui sont chez eux certains
qui rendent du travail etc et à
l'endroit de ta maison tu ne vois que tu
as de cendre
[Musique]
avec le bonus ça passe là dans les
décombres de la maison tu aperçois
quelque chose qui a l'air d'avoir été un
peu épargné
j'ai arrêté de secouer les cendres là
c'est
quelque chose
un objet épargné par les flammes
continue de se coller Sandra c'est une
photo oui et tu reconnais ta femme sur
cette photo si je vous ai fait
avec un message
à ta mémoire de l'amour de ma vie
Frédéric petit
c'est Joséphine ne devint c'est ma tombe
curieux comme
pardon
je suis un peu
c'est écriture de José ça
j'ai disparu
ou si vous êtes morte
pour le coup ils étaient restés derrière
du coup tu vois écrit sur la tombe bon
c'est pas sur cette image parce que
juste c'est pas graphiste du coup juste
pris une image libre de droit voilà
sur la sur la tombe là c'est pas marqué
sur l'image mais tu vois marquer que
2029 date de décès
ça veut dire aussi
elle vous a cherché
ça me rappelle un film que j'ai vu à la
télé
est-ce que les visiteurs
ben je connais pas ça parce que
finalement ce serait pas
dédoubler
ça serait pas un voyage dans le temps
mais un voyage dans l'espace
ou alors on a réussi à rentrer
après vous êtes mort
S
[Musique]
vous arrivez au bar
yes
effectivement il est très animé vous
rentrez
bonne ambiance à l'intérieur du bar
beaucoup de gens il y a des gens qui
mangent des gens qui boivent il y a de
tout
ça
UE
j'espère qu'ils ont Frank Sinatra
vraiment super
je m'approche des personnes qui servent
oui
et je demande oui bonjour bonjour voilà
vous avez oublié une thème pour quatre
pour quatre et puis j'aimerais juste
savoir on est en train de de voyager un
petit peu là on est passé
on va justement savoir si vous avez déjà
vous avez déjà visité à Marie-Lys
[Musique]
oui oui mais en voyage
du coup c'est plus difficile de voyager
dis ce sera 2 dollars
la prochaine c'est pour moi
ok très bien oui ça marche on va payer
plus tard
donc le voyage le voyage oui parce que
on pose des questions oui on me demande
aussi oui vous avez jamais été à Amélie
tout ça vous avez jamais fait le petit
périple c'est très sympa surtout en
cette saison d'après-midi
pour la différence que ça fait
aujourd'hui à l'extérieur que ça se
rafraîchit vous avez des
[Musique]
de sa part ce matin ou peut-être qu'il
est toujours en ville il s'appelle
Damien pouvoir non pardon attendez non
j'ai confondu pardon romain Delim
d'olive
[Musique]
parce que pour le voyage on réfléchit
voilà c'est ce fou quoi
mais aussi on aime bien voilà comprendre
un peu la recherche scientifique tout ça
ce qui se passe est-ce que vous avez
connaissance d'une autre parce que là on
vient de sortir de
Elixia fascinant vraiment super un des
meilleurs concepts store là que j'ai
jamais vu mais par contre on aimerait
voir s'il y a d'autres choses dans la
région du même à Kaby tout simplement
dans la région oui je suis scientifique
quoi qu'ils font des choses
[Musique]
je sais pas moi je sais pas trop
ici j'ai connu des gens un petit peu
plus
où va la jeunesse d'élixia de toute
façon ça fait 2000 ans qu'elle va vers
le bas
[Musique]
on peut se retourner à notre table
ok bon moi franchement je sais pas dans
quel monde on vit je reconnais plus rien
ce que je vous ai pas dit dans la pièce
là parce que moi j'ai l'impression de
devenir fou déjà je vois des des formes
humanoïdes voilà je vous en ai parlé
quoi
une voix qui vous parle Monsieur Pierre
[Musique]
j'ai un peu peur mais alors là quand
j'étais dans la dans la salle au Spadium
j'ai trouvé cette note
je voulais nous la lire
nous oui elle dit quoi elle me dit que
ma descendance plus fort il y a de la
musique je vous rappelle
elle dit c'est ma descendante qui dit
c'est fort la musique j'ai réussi j'ai
pu créer une brèche dans l'espace-temps
qui m'a permis de voir le passé d'un
d'un court instant donc bref c'est elle
la personne que j'avais vu c'était ma
descendante vous avez une fille alors
200 heures je pense c'est un peu plus de
génération quoi
[Musique]
toi quand il parle de sa descendance
fais-moi un jeu d'intelligence ah oui
oui plein
alors pendant qu'il parle du coup je
fais ça
tu n'as pas d'idée
[Rires]
ou pas
faites attention aux scientifiques
du coin c'est pour ça que je posais des
questions mais voilà on avance à rien
donc j'essaye de voilà et qu'elle a
entendu parler dans l'ancien laboratoire
souterrain où elle s'est installée pour
faire ses recherches une me contacter et
elle m'a dit voilà si tu dis ces mots je
suis ta descendante retrouve-moi dans ce
laboratoire secret tu devrais pouvoir te
débrouiller pour le trouver
malheureusement bon alors encore une
fois les gens sont pas très loquace je
pense qu'il y a eu quelque chose enfin
voilà ils ont peur 200 ans de jeunesse
je pense qu'ils ont peur des ailes de
rouge
ah ouais mais là de la censure
temporelle c'est quoi ça donc il faut
qu'on trouve ce laboratoire souterrain
sans que les gens sachent qu'on cherche
nous les scientifiques mais oui c'est
nous les sciences
alors par contre juste ça c'est de la
petite connaissance économique mais
l'argent c'est plus la même donc là
juste pour vous dire on n'a pas d'argent
nous va falloir juste partir
combien vous avez vous
on a de l'argent de maintenant là enfin
on a de l'argent je pense que l'argent a
changé entre en 200 ans là après ce
qu'ils ont vraiment eu le temps de ce
pulser sur le système économique je
pense oui
actuellement oui
mais
nous allons tester
allez-y moi je pars
je vais payer d'accord très bien je
jouerai la vieille dame voilà très bien
pas question de tu vas me faire non mais
je sors j'ai tellement de confiance en
moi que ça se tu es en train de
patienter dans la rue fais-moi un jeu
d'intelligence tous intelligent et tu as
un bonus
ah oui bah oui 20% de la descendance
elle est descendante l'intelligence là
[Musique]
tu as combien bah moi je pense quand
même
pour cent de bonus
65 donc ça passe tout pile grâce au jazz
du coup je vais te dire à quoi tu penses
juste après vous donc vous venez pour
payer surtout
8 dollars
alors je vois rien je suis désolé que
cette obscurité avec mes lunettes je ne
vois pas ce que j'ai alors là obtenez
regardez je vous donne tout garder la
monnaie et merci pour cet accueil
c'était charmant
c'est super rare merci
je ne sais pas voilà non mais t'es pas
c'est très bien je pense que là alors en
fait c'était ma tante c'est en fait on
allait vous laisser un pourboire mais
elle est pas tout laisser l'argent donc
si je pouvais récupérer
ma petite
si je peux vous récupérer mais bien sûr
on va vous laisser un pourboire on sait
que c'est de la vieille monnaie
vous voulez me donner combien de pouvoir
du coup parce que je vous rends combien
on vous donne on vous donne deux
donc si vous préférez je prends pas
votre argent et vous ramener de l'argent
d'ici mais on peut faire ça
je vais faire le change et on revient
vous payer
de mettre dessus
le général il s'amuse pas donner des
papiers comme ça
je peux vous le dire on leur donne
n'importe qui des aigles rouges si vous
êtes chez eux mais vous les connaissez
ou pas
c'est des papiers ah moi c'est pas la
première personne qui serait venu et du
coup je peux pas vous croire sur parole
vous comprenez sinon n'importe qui qui
arrive qui dit général j'en ai un petit
peu marre d'attendre surtout que là
j'étais super intelligent donc du coup
tu as une idée en fait grâce à ton jeu
d'intelligence d'accord tu te dis c'est
devenu quoi la CCI
le bureau de la CCI oui oui très bien ah
c'est le tour de la nostalgie là qu'on
fait
j'observe voir ce qui se passe dans le
dans le parc
et je vais vers Fredo et je dis bon on a
autre chose à faire allons-y c'est parti
faut payer quoi
mais on récupère toute la monnaie
qu'elle a donné quoi donc il faut
récupérer 40 c'est ça
vous sortez il commence à faire bien
frais à l'extérieur
ok bon où est-ce qu'on va si vous avez
trop froid j'ai une cape mais c'est
peut-être pas le bon moment pour la
mettre
on a plus la cape
je relis ma lettre là laboratoire
souterrain
c'est souterrain ça c'est sous le niveau
de la terre effectivement et je me suis
dit qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur le niveau de
la terre plus de terre
les sous-sols de la CCI les sous-sols de
la CCI et oui les sous-sols de la CCI
tous les secrets des commissaires
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais c'est là pour cacher la personne
qui oui qui écrivait les sirènes
oui donc du coup je me dis vu que c'est
ma descendante peut-être que vous avez
un laissé aller
à laisser aller laisser passer peut-être
on y va vite fait on regarde le sous-sol
voir peut-être qu'il y a un labo secret
bon ce serait étonnant
les papiers un peu étranges la lettre
des pires à l'air
c'est parti on bon du coup
les anciens bureaux de la CCI et en fait
en arrivant vision effroyable pour toi
il y a plus le bureau de la CCI
remplacer par un bâtiment où il y a des
grandes lettres en néon où il y a marqué
Flappy
je fais une petite danse de la
célébration excusez-moi hop notre
bandeau est bien mise là je prends
absolument toute mon humilité et mon
humanité et je fais
ouais non mais bon après c'est si vous
voulez c'est un échec mais qui appelle
un succès
que je dirais simplement que ça n'a pas
marché en l'occurrence pour vous ça a
marché pour moi j'imagine a été déménagé
dans un lieu avec beaucoup plus de
classe avec beaucoup plus de
d'ambition même si c'est vrai que bon et
oui là je vous montre juste les colonnes
en marbre là
dans l'entreprise est-ce qu'il y a un
tapis rouge par terre à quoi ça
ressemble de toute façon
très luxueux
et très très ambiance start-up
[Musique]
mais il est très vieux quoi enfin c'est
ça c'est rien
sur des vieilles balles pour le coup
c'est très très bien entre nous ah oui
d'accord ah ouais quand même
RGB et il y a une photo d'une personne
qui te ressemble
un cadre comme ça
on dirait vous
c'est vrai
c'est dingue
c'est votre bâtiment vous le connaissez
je connais pas ce bâtiment
[Musique]
je veux dire on venait d'être incubé
enfin bon c'est moi quoi
vous étiez où la pie c'était où flapi en
mettait un cubé à l'intérieur de de
comment ça s'appelle
[Rires]
[Musique]
après je vais vous dire une CCI ça ne
meurt jamais ça reste donc
[Musique]
peut-être
qu'il y a aussi un sous-sol qu'on
pourrait peut-être ça c'est un levier
d'action
c'est votre descendant
je fais comme toujours sur le comptoir
et je dis ma petite Laura
ouvrez-nous les portes du du sous-sol je
le dis sans rire
je ne sais pas qui vous êtes enfin je me
mets à côté du portrait et je
[Musique]
madame bidon n'était pas en train de
faire un jogging elle avait un
rendez-vous d'affaires cet après-midi et
je pense qu'elle va bientôt sortir mais
du coup je pense que Madame bidon est
plus au courant de son propre planning
que son planning est au courant d'elle
écoutez actuellement
ce que vous pouvez
oui
[Musique]
euh ça vous a l'air pas
du coup elle appelle sur un truc elle
dit bon bah il y a quelqu'un à l'accueil
qui dit que c'est vous
du coup je pense que c'est pas vous
rapidement parce que je sais pas trop
quoi lui dire
et est-ce que c'est un appel visio non
d'accord bah j'attendrai à l'heure
il y a une femme qui descend du coup la
femme du tableau pas toi
qui est bon c'est quoi cette histoire
je vais la voir
je dis bonjour églantine bidon
qui êtes-vous
[Musique]
je suis ton père
comment ça églantine bidon c'est moi
c'est moi tu ne me reconnais pas regarde
je suis la seule à savoir faire ça
tu me reconnais maintenant
13 OK
[Rires]
je viens du passé pour te prévenir d'un
terrible danger qui se passe dans ton
monde actuellement donc tu es au courant
il fait tout noir on a un problème et il
nous faut plus de Spadium
fais nous on fait de pétrole ah oui
la boîte marche bien d'ailleurs
CCI yes parfait est-ce que j'ai toujours
mes actions en tant que actionnaire
fondateur
non
oui oui on a besoin de quoi un bureau
allez-y un bureau
dans un bureau et parler parce que elle
va nous parler du coup elle a confiance
en toi oui oui est-ce qu'on peut avoir
ton bureau
[Musique]
moi j'étais très souvent sur le monde
sauce pour Nikos Nikos je ne sais plus
pour fou
est-ce qu'on peut parler à bâton rompu
non il n'est pas disponible
alors ça veut dire parler sans emballage
bien fait dedans c'est-à-dire aller
directement droit au but dites-moi
dites-moi et bien tout simplement pour
parler d'une manière la plus claire
possible
c'est que nous cherchons à
retourner chez nous objectif numéro 1
éventuellement si entre temps on peut
résoudre votre problème la galère quand
même vraiment ça c'est quand même la
tuile quoi si on peut résoudre vos
problèmes de noir
qui fait tout noir voilà
c'était voilà moi j'ai quand même une
question je comprends quelque chose que
je comprends pas pourquoi à quoi vous
sert le pétrole
pour le générateur quand même ça c'était
non mais je sais pas j'ai l'impression
que tout fonctionner au Spadium
a juste la lumière non le Spadium c'est
une bonne source effectivement mais nous
on a fait fortune dans le pétrole et ça
reste le premier d'accord c'est l'avant
vous avez des comptes vous avez des
contacts on a toujours du pétrole et
vous vendez le pétrole pas que à alixia
oui bien sûr on exporte
donc vous vous d'accord à Marie-Lise
tout ça vous connaissez
oui d'accord
[Musique]
pour une fois on a des réponses et du
coup tu es là pour combien de temps
parce que c'est bizarre
par contre peut-être que tu pourrais me
donner un coup de main pour Flappy je
sais pas est-ce que tu travailles encore
travailler pour Flappy ah bah avec
plaisir attends on Flappy c'est mon bébé
sinon on a repéré enfin on a entendu
parler d'une ancienne raffinerie que
nous arrangerait bien mais elle est un
peu perdue à proximité d'iris alors là
je sors mon plan de
la mairie
iridis oui je vois iridis il y a une
raffinerie là-bas si tu passes par là et
que par le plus grand des hasards tu
trouves un moyen de trouver cette
raffinerie parce qu'on nous on envoie on
a envoyé quelques expéditions on n'a pas
réussi à trouver
tu me préviens
militaires
on veut bien aller là-bas pour vous oui
vous auriez pas un petit truc un peu
écolo un 4x4
comment vous comment vous envoyez vos
commandes comment vous envoyez le
pétrole dans les autres villages on a
des livreurs est-ce qu'on peut se
greffer sur un livreur oui on se met
dans la coffre peut-être
vous vous regardez peut-être avec mon
livreur j'en ai un qui est en ville
depuis aujourd'hui je crois qu'il doit
repartir demain et bah voilà
moi je me penche vers Pierre-Alain donc
il y a que Pierre Harley
on est quand même là pour le Souter
c'est vrai
ma biche il y avait pas une histoire de
de
Pierre Alain qui voulait te parler
[Musique]
est-ce que vous savez s'il y a d'autres
parce que là on a on vient de d'alixia
où il y a un complexe de scientifiques
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres complexes de
scientifiques comme ça qui j'ai entendu
des recherches de Gaia
ce qu'on m'a dit des recherches mais je
sais pas est-ce que c'est un laboratoire
souterrain par hasard non non
les plantes
vous seriez pas ou laboratoire
souterrain tout ça ça vous dit rien
je crois que vous vouliez enfin ça vous
auriez ça vous aurait fait plaisir de
revoir vos archives
vraiment j'adore me plonger dans les
vieux papiers là et Gloria adore aussi
tu nous ouvrirais les portes je sais pas
d'une pièce par exemple au sous-sol oui
mais après je sais que il y a beaucoup
de trucs et pas que des trucs de chez
nous bah justement on regarde un peu
vite fait juste pour se rapprocher
des anciennes des anciens articles de
presse ou quelque chose comme bonjour
quelque chose on y accède comment
pour une fois on a des gens qui nous
amènent quelque part on va en profiter
vous êtes dans une grande salle où il y
a plein de placards dans tous les sens
et normalement de documents elle est
avec nous ok
qu'est-ce que vous cherchez mais
juste je prends un petit moment à part
sans qu'elle entende pour demander aux
autres vous avez retenu son prénom
[Musique]
Sophie madame bidon
après il y a bien son nom quelque part
enfin je veux dire les gens dans les
entreprises normalement
on a lu la plaquette c'est sous le
portrait donc en fait on sait
est-ce que perception pouvoir
48 perception c'est où tac tac tac 40
sur 45 minutes
[Musique]
merci moi j'aimerais bien je peux je
prends Amélie à part
[Musique]
vous m'avez parlé d'une photo que vous
m'auriez vu sur une folie je sais pas
mais c'est peut-être quelque part là
dans les archives d'ailleurs
si vous êtes une amie de de mon à la
grand-mère ou arrière-grand-mère je ne
sais pas de amis n'hésitez pas à
fouiller votre année de mort peut-être
ça pourrait être un bon point de départ
oui je vois pas comment une date
de presse de 2029 où il y aurait
éventuellement une photo d'un monsieur
avec un béret exactement ça direct
méthode pour une fois que c'est pas des
articles de presse
[Musique]
je ne suis pas là
dis donc vous avez pris un coup de pelle
quand même depuis est-ce que quelqu'un
peut lire un peu ça haute voix pour les
gens qui écoutent un peu le lire vas-y
articles édition du 14 avril 2029
horizon news
fin du chantier de centrale donc c'est
sur un côté
donc il écrit monsieur Chicheportiche
présidente de la CCI à communiquer sur
la fin du chantier de centrale
géothermique pour rappel la construction
avait été grandement ralenti par la
découverte de vestiges sélénite il a
accepté de s'entretenir avec nous en
page 4 pour revenir sur l'histoire et
l'utilité de ce chantier
et à côté il y a la photo moi Fredo les
bras croisés avec écrit catastrophe à
Elixia au dessus
et écrit lors d'une expérience sur le
spolium au sein du complexe Elixia le
concierge Frédéric petit a perdu la vie
à cause d'une erreur de calcul
je suis mort en 2029 sur le alors après
vous savez
un peu à Mario sur cette photo oui
vraiment quelque chose
aussi
c'est la dernière phase dont je me
rappelle du chantier les niveaux
sélénitent
2029 je suis disparu en 2023 comprendra
après ouais
parce que monsieur a fini le chantier là
d'accord
ça veut dire que en 2029 on travaille
déjà sur le spolium
qui est actuellement dans notre présent
en fait c'est là que vous êtes mort
un accident ce qui nous est arrivé
c'était une tentative de de sauver le
futur qui a actuellement le président de
nous de nous évincer de nous faire
disparaître
à quel moment quel truc il nous est
arrivé je pense que ma découverte de ces
vestiges sélénite ou la construction ou
de ma centrale géothermique c'est
multifactoriels comme de bien entendu
j'ai du mal avec les constructions de
phrases en ce moment c'est la fatigue je
peux m'invitaminer peut-être
les pages parce que là il y a page 4
élixir
est-ce que vous pouvez essayer de
trouver la page 4 et page 6 parce que là
il y a que ça et ma tête les archives
est-ce qu'on peut mieux trouver
est-ce que on peut chercher d'autres non
on cherche tout à d'autres d'autres
je voudrais chercher Céline non je
voudrais chercher
s'il y a des choses plus il y a pas mal
de trucs en fait c'est un musée qui
s'appelle le musée sélénite dans horizon
qui a été fondé par toi oh j'étais sûr
ah oui j'étais sûr oui c'est vrai
aux alentours des 2025
parce que là il écrit j'ai essayé de
fait son premier anniversaire excuse-moi
surtout les archives
de presse quand même quand on a disparu
j'espère
que
je suis mort bah oui mais une photo
enfin on sait pas ou quoi une expérience
mais non on peut pas encore exister
parce que 200 ans quand même c'est long
chercher
aigle rouge calmez-vous monsieur
attendez votre attention
je cherche
voilà et puis aussi on cherche tous les
noms de villages
et de Gaïa
nous racontons-nous perception
60 sur
allez j'espère 40 je trouve
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux chercher à mon tour
bah moi j'ai pas cherché 38
tac tac 48
tu cherches mais moi je cherche aussi tu
trouves pas tout 41 tu vas trouver deux
trucs
que tu
peux savoir si je sais pas trop
de donner une liste de choses que vous
voulez chercher tu en trouves
gaillard peut-être
des informations amaryllis peut-être
comme ça
il va nous dire il y a le marché de la
jonquille
on peut dire si je sportive déjà il y a
forcément des infos sur vous si vous
avez disparu du jour au lendemain et
vous êtes peut-être pas important
forcément avoir des trucs on parle là
dessus ça vous va oui alors
Chicheportiche pour commencer s'il vous
plaît
tu envoies un surtout qui te soit aux
yeux où il y a marqué décès de Monsieur
Alain Chicheportiche lors de son
quatrième mandat
en entreprise
une rue à son nom a été je sais plus
quoi je sais pas compris l'inauguré oui
donc j'étais pas là quoi c'est dommage
ça doit faire 2030 et quelques
récemmentionne pas si le chantier de la
chambre basse oui si c'était déjà fini
le la centrale géothermique
aucune information de plus sur dans
l'article non rien de spécial pas de
félicitations du maire de si tu vois que
ça t'en sens quand même
rendu un grand
[Musique]
je sais pas si vous avez je voudrais
chercher je peux j'ai 41 sur 70 non mais
il me reste un truc que j'ai trouvé
mon niveau
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr que ce soit une très
bonne idée
c'est important pour Hélène alors on va
dire Gaïa
qui vous dit bon je suis désolé mais moi
je vais devoir fermer fermer boutique
comme on dit tu commences à se faire ça
vous avez un logement
non non
de
la chambre d'hôtel de cette nuit si vous
voulez
donne ça au gérant de l'hôtel de 10 quel
hôtel à quel hôtel
super merci et alors pour le pour le
livreur demain est-ce que tu sais à peu
près où est-ce qu'on peut le trouver où
il va accessoire
retrouvez-le ici devant Flappy à 11h ok
ça c'est mes horaires ça j'aime bien
merci Amélie
je maintiens que si le labo il était là
on l'a pas vu quoi on l'a pas cherché en
fait
c'est l'ancienne CCI ici
exactement
je sais même pas si c'est un vrai truc
ça
j'invente
ils vont pas nous chercher ils vont pas
se demander je pense que ce serait pas
mal de retourner voir le machin bolieux
là
l'office du tourisme c'était génial mais
ça fout de ça il nous a envoyé
en mission aussi on revient c'était
sympa on a bu des bières
on a parlé à des gens ils nous ont dit
oui le Spadium mais on est sur la piste
on va perdre on y travaille moi je pense
on va se faire engueuler il a pas
confiance en nous et on va aller le voir
pour lui dire
excusez-moi 73
Ibiza je comprends
ça c'était
bon vieux temps
est-ce que est-ce qu'on aurait quand
même pas besoin d'un laisser passer de
la part du général je suis en recroise
les Aigles rouges pour leur dire et
regarder on a envoyé par lui nous
embêtez pas quoi un petit papier quoi
moi je pense qu'on peut y arriver à
avoir un laisser passer pour comme ça là
on modifie le laisser passer de non
n'importe quoi oui on peut essayer il
est tard ou quelle heure il est 23 ans
[Musique]
il fait beaucoup plus froid
le froid est pénétrant quoi d'accord
donc vous montrer le papier que amelita
fait la personne à l'accueille vous dire
d'accord bon ben je vais vous donner des
chambres et apparemment c'est c'est
réglé d'avance
avec une baignoire
des cachots pourris
quand même là on est mieux donc vous
arrivez dans l'hôtel vous vous posez sur
chacun dans vos champs vous avez une
chambre chacun
vous allez passer une bonne nuit de
sommeil et du coup on peut peut-être en
profiter pour faire une pause et prendre
une douche bien
donc vous avez fait effectivement une
bonne nuit de sommeil à l'hôtel toi tu
te fais réveiller par bouga qui était
dans ta chambre avec
et Gloria tu vas me faire un lancer de
rythme décalé
ouais vous allez voir les gars
j'ai 50 tu fais du jet lag à 55
tous les trois de vous retrouver dans le
couloir il y a pas Gloria
ben on va toquer à sa porte
bon j'arrive à sa porte voilà
peut-être qu'elle est morte dans son
sommeil vous avez vu son âge
[Musique]
on revient la chercher plus tard elle a
besoin de dormir elle a besoin de dormir
vous savez comment c'est à son âge on ne
va pas la bonne année
vous pouvez pas parler alors
je serai d'avis quand même ça m'inquiète
on a dormi longtemps quand même on a
fait une bonne nuit moi je suis bien
reposé on part on va partir manger on
prend le petit déj de l'hôtel et puis on
revient dans 30 minutes on mange des
crêpes
parce que vous aviez vraiment le ventre
en vrac ça fait bien parce que ça fait
longtemps que tu as pas mangé quelque
chose du coup oui mais voilà je suis
résistant mais ça va donc voilà vous
faites votre petit déj l'heure avant
gentiment bah on va remonter chercher
madame cross parce que à 11h il faut
qu'on me parte on lui fait une assiette
de condiments
l'odeur ça va la faire seulement
il faut
vous apportez le petit déjeuner il faut
qu'on y aille mais condiments
iche
on se retrouve au Jazz Club tout à
l'heure non mais là on part de Elixia en
fait de horizon peut-être je ne sais pas
sinon petite proposition c'est vrai que
quand même on a bien voyagé tout ça on
peut peut-être juste se reposer ce matin
et puis on part dans l'après-midi
[Musique]
écoutez je vous propose qu'on fasse une
diligence oui j'emploie des mots comme
ça ce matin c'est ça de prendre des
petits déjeuners ça me vaut et donc par
exemple Fredo et moi on pourra aller
voir ou alors Monsieur
on peut aller voir Monsieur le général
et on lui demande si là par exemple une
voiture en plus du lycée
madame Frost par exemple vous voyez
genre un pick-up on a ben derrière et
comme ça on peut rouler avec elle qui
dort
pour qu'on fasse ça et si jamais il nous
dit non à ce moment-là on se rabat sur
le on y va on retourne au QG le rouge ok
c'est y aller et on va voir généralement
d'accord
son bureau
j'essaie d'ouvrir la porte fermée c'est
fermé
je vois une garde un soldat là dans le
couloir je lui dis excusez-moi on
cherche le général Beaulieu il est en
déplacement
en déplacement loin
je peux pas vous dire
est-ce que vous avez entendu parler des
gens qui viennent du passé ouais on a eu
un brief ce matin très bien alors Fredo
du passé
petit
non
monsieur Beaulieu le général Beaulieu
nous a confié pour mission de nous
renseigner sur
vous êtes au courant très bien on va
gagner du temps nous aimerions un
véhicule pour nous déplacer un véhicule
motorisé
on a une des membres de l'expédition qui
est très mal en point
à vous donner et vous pouvez même des
véhicules français c'est pas forcément
des véhicules vous pouvez pas venir avec
nous si
de vélo
des vélos cargo peut-être des
trottinettes électriques
on m'a pas dit de vous fournir de
véhicules je vais pas faire ça
vous avez quand même été briefé que
Monsieur le général
nous a demandé nous a confié une mission
vous avez le brief ça oui comment vous
voulez qu'on mène à bien la mission si
on n'a pas les bons outils trouver
quelqu'un qui peut vous transporter
il y a plein de gens qui font des
allers-retours entre les villes entre
les villages alentours de type il y a
une gare routière peut-être il y a un
blablacar quelque chose
il y a des routes ou quoi il y a
merci pour votre aide
madame est-ce que on irait pas faire du
stop finalement chercher voir quelqu'un
qui serait prêt à transporter tous les
quatre
on peut aller voir le plan du
livre on peut aller voir peut-être le
livreur peut vous demander rien d'autre
tant que vous êtes occupé
on n'aurait pas on nous aurait pas
monsieur général nous aurait pas laissé
passer par hasard pour nous aider un peu
est-ce que vous appelez un laisser
passer boire quelque chose qui puisse
trouver qu'on est de bonne foi
un papier officiel pour dire que c'est
lui qui nous manque quoi quelque part
quelque chose c'est lui qui nous livre
un bureau il suffit d'un truc il
tamponne puis que merci beaucoup allez
super et on est quitte
encore une fois de réveiller madame
je tente
non mais je dis oui
madame couperose mais de plus en plus
fort
il est l'heure de se lever
on a beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire
j'ai entendu parler de
sélénite il faut qu'on aille voir les
Sélénites
oui le musée est là déjà vous m'avez
bien saoulé avec ça alors maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on aille le voir s'il vous
plaît vous allez pas être difficile avec
ça et plus trop de lumière mes lunettes
quoi alors quoi sélénite oui bon
maintenant que je vous ai descendez
venez on va manger le le petit déjeuner
on les attend pour
on n'est plus à l'hôtel
non et puis à l'hôtel je ne sais pas je
pars
nous on est revenu de pendant ce temps
on est revenu à l'hôtel
je ne suis pas du matin
je ne dors pas la nuit donc le matin je
récupère avec Madame Bidart on a réussi
à se procurer un laisser passer qui
teste un laissé aller récépissé
bon ils ont pas de véhicule les Aigles
rouges
peut-être que ils peuvent voilà bon du
coup enfin vu que vous êtes réveillés de
toute façon on a plus besoin de vous
transporter dans le coffre donc
un peu on peut toujours
faire ce ferme pas de porte donc on va
directement au livreur voir où il va et
à mon avis ce qu'on le suit ou pas je
pense on va lui demander s'il veut bien
nous déjà peut-être
de dire on va avec lui peut-être lui
demander où il va
oui oui oui
on se dirige vers vous sortez de l'hôtel
il y a un gars en face de la rue qui est
en train de fumer une clope et quand il
vous voit j'ai sa clope et il s'avance
d'un pas décidé vers vous il tient une
mallette
je l'aime tout de suite c'est le livreur
quelle est la règle
comment tu veux qu'il soit dans Google
après il est pas il est c'est un chien
il est pas futé non plus quoi mais bon
il arrive
pas en avance
[Musique]
je comprends ça veut dire un petit
travail facile
[Musique]
enfin je veux dire on n'a pas besoin
d'argent
[Musique]
excusez-moi j'ai perdu le nom c'est
bizarre
iste belge
Benoît
je vous donne cette mallette vous
l'ouvrez pas vous allez à iridis vous
donner à une certaine Lara
et vous êtes graphique c'est tout non
merci
en même temps on est déjà mais on peut
avoir de l'argent madame
[Musique]
on peut rentrer chez nous on est en plus
riche
excusez-moi je parle à mes collègues je
prends pas la mallette d'un type que je
connais pas non mais oui vous le
rendriez bien
est-ce que vous avez préparé vous même
votre bagage
merci mais on gagne combien quel est
l'intérêt
je suis déjà grave moi j'ai pas besoin
de donc je pourrais facilement dire à
Lara que Frédéric petit a refusé mon
offre oui avec grand plaisir
si vous voyez la râpe et vous pourrez
lui donner la mallette voilà
c'est comme ça que Frédéric petit a
refusé son offre exactement
vous la connaissez et puis moi j'aurais
pas envie de transport
j'aime bien les malettes je les
collectionne oui mais vous êtes avec
nous donc vous avez l'air plus
intelligent que votre collègue
[Musique]
vous voulez ce travail c'est facile
ça suffit pas les sensations ça y est ça
fait deux jours on est en 2000 ou 200 et
on s'ennuie déjà il faut savoir saisir
les opportunités quand elles se
présentent
maximum je vous tue la race sera au
courant
solution je ne pousse comme ça je fais
écoute
tu vas arrêter de nous casser les burnes
et tu nous laisses tranquille
et je me mets à chanter du Lara Fabian
dans ma tête
d'accord
je suis en plus que la chanter
mon désespoir un truc comme ça peut-être
continuer
[Rires]
je suis malade
on continue notre chemin vous vous
rendez du coup devant flapi où il y a
effectivement un véhicule qui vous
attend c'est ça parfait alors ça c'est
bon
il se présente à vous qui vous dit
Amélie m'a dit que je vais vous
transporter
si vous pouvez nous déposer dans le
centre d'iridis alors moi je veux bien
par contre on va pouvoir passer un des
check point des aigles rouges pour
sortir de la ville du coup il faut une
autorisation pas de souci
je lui montre je le garde dans la main
ok ok nickel bon bah on peut partir si
vous êtes prêts
custom avec des gros néons
donc j'ai pas suivi
lairidis
spolium et je fais c'est ma route en
fait je vais à iridy je récupère les
marchandises
un peu la plaque tournante de du
commerce de la région et après je me
livrer les villages
je m'adresse à mes collègues là le plan
c'est quoi là c'est
on le cherche toujours le souterrain
quoi
et si on peut on continue le trajet avec
lui oui mais pour moi il faut trouver ce
souterrain là c'est le oui mais est-ce
qu'il faut pas qu'on prospecte un petit
peu partout
vous voulez pas vous voulez
de ma fille
[Rires]
amusez-vous
[Musique]
le résultat du prochain sondage ça m'a
fait
vous partez vers
le trajet
alors d'abord vous passez le checkpoint
des aigles rouges
on va vers l'ouest
et regarde ton papier il dit ok très
bien
merci
donc effectivement vous prenez la route
vers riddis vous traversez un pont assez
rapidement et il nous raconte nous
raconte donc l'histoire
je vous décris un peu le véhicule
donc en fait dans le à l'intérieur de la
cabine du véhicule je sais plus comment
on dit à l'intérieur d'un cabine
qui vous éclaire du coup vous pouvez
vous voir les uns les autres et il y a
des grands projecteurs qui éclairent la
route loin devant mais genre sur 10 15
mètres pas plus spolium quoi en gros oui
on a l'habitude maintenant mais du coup
c'est pas bien éclairé sur les côtés
derrière c'est vraiment c'est très vite
noir
donc il vous dit ben Lara écouter
vaut mieux pas trop le chercher des noix
mais pourquoi qu'est-ce que c'est qui
c'est quelqu'un d'influent
en commun
vis-à-vis d'elle j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver mort c'est une action
[Musique]
où elle est plus que d'habitude qu'on
doit éviter
je pense que vous pourriez
potentiellement la croiser n'importe où
s'amuse à frapper les gens dans la rue
sans raison mais vaut mieux pas la voir
tu dois d'un mauvais œil quoi mais du
coup est-ce que iridi c'est sous ça
houlette
officieusement oui
non non
mais comment ça pour le moment de ce que
j'ai compris j'ai le temps de leur
influence et
d'accord
c'est de récupérer le pouvoir dans les
villages avoisinants
donc là on va directement sur sur ready
c'est ça on passe par d'autres coins
vous avancez sur le trajet quand tout à
coup
romain pile et dit oh c'est quoi ça
encore
vous vous retrouvez bloqué par un
éléphant
sur la route c'est du colis je descends
avec Oba ah non je fais allez
[Musique]
on avait quelques bêtes qu'est-ce que tu
fais avec Google décris-moi pourquoi il
aboie
comme ça oui
j'ai bricolé
[Rires]
le Roi Lion à boire
et on se met un peu derrière les vaches
ça fait bouger les vaches parce qu'elles
ont un peu peur du chien
d'habitude enfin quand ça m'arrive je me
retrouve bloqué pendant des fois des
heures
supplémentaire vous êtes bien bravo
[Musique]
je sais pas alors si elle te mette à me
charger
comme elles sont mignonnes
mais c'est des braves bêtes c'est très
bon
je sais pas où Brest spolium si c'est
bon mais ça se mange hein c'est très bon
voilà ok bon ben vous reprenez la route
du coup gentiment vers Heredis
c'est ça avoir les paraguiculteurs
merci Fredo on enrichissement vous
passez non parce que sinon c'est vrai
que des vaches là oh là comment
peut-être au salon de l'agriculture
d'horizon
quand on est président de CCI
génératrice votre vache ça fait un petit
peu partie du Béaba enfin je veux dire
ça mais on oublie souvent on voit déjà
en costard mais derrière il y a un cœur
et encore derrière il y a un cerveau
d'agriculteur et oui ça rime
sur une route particulièrement
accidentée plongée dans cette brume
obscure qui donne l'impression que vous
n'avancez pas une lumière bleue finit
par apparaître au loin
comme si elle essaie de percer la brume
vous supposez d'abord que c'est un autre
véhicule ou une personne à pied mais
elle grandit si lentement que cette
hypothèse vous semble impossible
en voyant votre surprise romain ricane
et vous dit que vous êtes bientôt arrivé
quelques minutes plus tard les
particules noires commencent à
s'amoniser notre conducteur ralentit et
vous dit moi je vous laisse là je vais
décharger mes marchandises plus loin au
plaisir de vous recroiser
vous retrouvez donc à l'entrée d'un
village enfin du village pardon une
gigantesque à les pavés regorgeant de
commerce et habitations en tout genre
donne droit sur le monument dont vous
n'arrivez pas vraiment à détacher vos
yeux une sorte de gigantesque feu de
joie de Spadium brûle au milieu de la
place centrale du village ce qui crée un
dôme de lumière qui chaperonne ce qui
semble être des dizaines d'échoppes
installés sur la place devant vous vous
voyez une grande pancarte en bois gravé
d'un simple message bienvenue à iridis
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vous a plu oui je note que
le roman il s'est foutu de notre gueule
parce qu'on voyait une lumière alors
qu'il savait pas virer les vaches là
[Musique]
on a super bien dormi à l'hôtel un
Gloria vous direz pas le contraire c'est
vrai que non mais j'ai un rythme décalé
oui je comprends c'est le jet lag infini
à la nuit j'écris j'écris j'écris
[Musique]
non j'abandonne
voilà une autre fois
du coup dans le chat là si vous avez des
questions sur quoi que ce soit n'hésitez
pas là c'est bon je laisse sous les yeux
moi je suis curieux de revenir sur la
monnaie parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'avant il s'est retenu
à la monnaie elle a pas changé en 200
ans mais
ouais
imagine on est passé du franc à l'euro
quoi enfin je veux dire de ton vivant tu
as changé de monnaie donc
change tout le temps de monnaie en fait
c'était en mode j'arrive de temps en
plus tard je paye avec moi ça m'a bu du
ginto ça va
choqué c'est tout en plus non
oui donc ça fait un peu raison quand
même de soulever ce point si vous avez
plus le voir dans les épisodes qui vient
parce que bon effectivement la monnaie
ça change assez vite et je pense que
dans une apocalypse ça change beaucoup
plus vite
parce qu'il y a un moment
en fait un truc
que mon prof
d'histoire-géo m'avait raconté j'étais
au lycée ou un truc comme ça voilà jeune
quand tout ça n'était pas arrivé
c'était qu'en fait le la partie la plus
importante sur un billet c'est enfin
d'aujourd'hui si vous regardez sur un
euro il y a toujours une signature et
c'est la signature de la fin de la
personne qui signe le billet aujourd'hui
c'est la personne qui lui donne sa
valeur donc c'est la là c'est la Banque
centrale européenne à chaque fois là
c'est de la gare oui c'est ça c'est la
garde qui signe tous les j'espère que je
dis pas de bêtises tu imagines c'est pas
elle mais si c'est après voilà
tu n'as pas la science infuse
et c'est cette signature qui en fait
d'une certaine manière donne de la
valeur à la monnaie parce que c'est
contre cette passer la garantie de la
Banque centrale européenne qui dit voilà
moi je vous garantis que cet argent là
il est voilà c'est ça et du coup ça on
l'avait parce que je reviens du musée de
Toulouse où il y avait toutes les
petites pièces là de romaine et tout ça
ou ça ou avant il y avait cette valeur
là qui était directement dans la pièce
donc c'est la
[Musique]
on s'autorise à
je sais pas un
denier enfin tu vois un truc on va le on
va le casser en deux et ça tu ajoutes tu
t'ajoutes du de
la monnaie physique quoi et ou même des
encoches ou alors tu refont les métaux
enfin c'est aussi ça c'est le refendre
les métaux pour finalement que ce soit
moins chargé en or mais que tu en es
plus en numéraire enfin voilà toutes ces
ça tu le vois un truc assez choquant
plus récent c'est quand on si on trouve
une collection de de pièces qui va de
1900 je sais pas de 1900 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fait on voit plein en
fait tu retrouves un petit peu toutes
les étapes de la France tu vois avec les
guerres ah là c'était un peu compliqué
tu vois les pièces qui commencent à
changer ou tout le métal il commence à
être un peu tout pourri et dans les
années
vers 39 enfin je crois que c'est ouais
vers 39 40 choses
et là du coup les pièces bon déjà elles
changent de symboles parce que du coup
c'était la il y avait une francise que
dessus le symbole de Vichy Pétain et
tout ça et
les métaux à cette époque là c'était
vraiment de l'aluminium mais vraiment
enfin les pièces elles font
elles ont pas de poids tu vois bien que
c'est un truc en top quoi ça vaut pas un
copek exactement c'est choquant de voir
ça de cette tu as des grosses pièces de
5 francs là et tu vois bien qu'elle
valait rien enfin je sais pas moi ça
m'avait vraiment
vraiment choqué de voir l'évolution tu
vois l'histoire en fait d'un pays à
travers chaque année ces monnaies
changent d'une certaine manière quoi et
peut-être que dans les villages qu'on va
parcourir on pourra regarder la monnaie
et la comparer j'espère que c'est prévu
en tout cas parce que s'il y a pas eu de
de
consulting money à quoi ça ressemble
dans une société
ce qui va se passer quoi ça va pas être
réaliste et c'est prévu ok en fait moi
je me dis dans un dans un monde où tu es
coupé de la civilisation entre gros
gamer au final cela actuellement la
monnaie on l'a récupéré des banques etc
si d'un coup genre les banques n'ont
plus d'incom en fait de je sais pas
comment dire ça mais en fait au bout
d'un moment la monnaie va se perdre et
va bien falloir un truc pour faire le
travail de la monnaie en fait bah ça y
est toujours enfin
un truc qui est intéressant je pense je
parle un peu sur ton contrôle aussi mais
c'est
tu as vu j'utilise des
choses
c'est que en fait dans l'histoire de la
monnaie et tu as plein aussi de trucs où
c'est des dettes qui sont pas forcément
sous forme de monnaie mais tu as très
rapidement un truc un peu central qui va
justement centraliser un peu ces toutes
ces dettes que les gens se
ont les uns envers les autres et qui
sert un peu de fluidif essaye de
fluidifier un peu le marché de serveur
de tiers de confiance mais du coup ce
tiers de confiance là ça peut être
n'importe qui dans nos sociétés on a
fait que c'est des banques centrales
parce que on s'est rendu compte que
c'est une institution qui fonctionne la
preuve c'est que ça dure mais ça peut
être plein d'autres institutions et tu
peux avoir des tu as plein de types de
monnaies différents qui peuvent émerger
dans différents contextes tu peux avoir
des monnaies à moitié je sais pas moi
militaire ou des à partir du moment où
tu mets des bons de ton enfin c'est
vraiment l'institution qui a un pouvoir
de contrôle du truc qui peut décider de
créer une monnaie c'est pour ça que
justement quand tu parlais à des pièces
à chaque empereur romain tu avais
vraiment le truc bam je refais mes
pièces avec ma tête
[Musique]
dans une société genre si demain là il y
avait cette catastrophe avec le
l'atmosphère qui se remplit et enfin
c'est la fin du monde quoi on serait
enfin le dernier truc qu'on aurait ce
serait les euros tu vois et du coup oui
mais là la signature elle vaut plus rien
enfin tu vois si la Banque centrale
européenne n'existe plus
il commence à y avoir un des gens qui
prennent un peu le contrôle et qui
disent ben en fait non les euros c'est
non ici on va utiliser cette monnaie et
c'est la nôtre en fait t'as pas le choix
que
c'est pour ça enfin là aujourd'hui c'est
une centralisation des monnaies enfin tu
vois c'est parce qu'il y a des espèces
de gros bloc économique qui se mettent
en place et qui se disent ok on va
utiliser les mêmes monnaies mais si tu
regardais au je crois que c'était aux
États-Unis dans les années
j'ai plus des années mais
1800 quelque chose en fait chaque ville
un peu avait sa monnaie et c'était enfin
tu avais un enfer de la en fait le fait
de regrouper c'est aussi pour faciliter
les échanges parce que là dans le
système là désolé je parle un peu
beaucoup mais après j'en ai fini très
bien c'est qu'en fait
à ce moment-là tu avais vraiment chaque
banque faisait sa monnaie et du coup tu
avais la banque de New York qui faisait
sa monnaie la banque de Philadelphie qui
faisait des abonnés on a fait un épisode
là-dessus un la banque de Denver qui
faisait sa monnaie et le problème si tu
veux c'est que d'une monnaie à l'autre
toi tu arrives avec tes dollars
new-yorkais de cette banque là tu as
rien fait et puis on est d'accord moi je
vais prendre tes billets mais donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut que j'attende que
quelqu'un d'autre vienne de New York tu
as un taux de change
ultime c'est la situation dans laquelle
on est dans le jeu
on sait pas on sait pas encore en fait
mais c'est possible que ce je vous donne
pas des idées mais c'est possible que ce
soit un truc comme ça tu vois et juste
pour finir sur ce truc là c'est qu'en
fait à la fin il y avait tellement ces
problèmes-là et plus on est loin de la
banque et maîtrise plus c'est dur
d'attendre quelqu'un qui va venir avec
avec les bons billets quoi du coup en
fait il y avait un espèce de livre où tu
disais bon bah si tu es à 800 miles de
fin tu vois si tu es à Denver et que tu
as quelqu'un qui vient avec des dollars
new-yorkais tu les accepte à tel tôt et
oui et genre ça devait être plus témoin
parce que tu es jamais sûr de retrouver
de récupérer de récupérer ta mise quoi
et la banque tu sais pas si elle existe
pour de vrai lui dit c'est de regarder
mes bobbies
aucune idée donc tu regardes dans ton
annuaire en mode est-ce que ça ressemble
mais après ça cette monnaie là qu'on
nous on connaît finalement c'est récent
dans l'histoire de l'humanité parce que
la plus grande partie de la vie des
humains ça a été le troc et finalement
le troc c'est ce qui donne de la valeur
aux choses c'est leur disponibilité dans
les gisements que ce soit des des
coquillages des pépites d'or des épices
tu vois on sous-estime vachement le
voilà ce que je sais pas ce que valait
les épices par exemple
jusqu'à ce qui est jusqu'à ce qui est
autre chose mais c'est et puis on le
voit toi l'anthropologie elle nous
montre qu'il y a des sociétés qui
résistent à au système monétaire elle
n'en veulent pas et ça c'est étonnant
c'est étonnant quand je sais qu'il y a
un épisode de Rendez-vous en terre
inconnue
qui est arrivé pour filmer une
population je crois que c'est en
Mongolie
et en échange ils ont donné au chef du
village bah beaucoup d'argent enfin en
fait ça a foutu la merde mais pendant
des années en fait c'est-à-dire que
c'est c'est
une donnée qui est irrecevable dans dans
certaines organisations c'est un peu
étonnant parce que l'argent papier a été
pas mal répondu par
l'Empire mongole justement quand il
s'est très grand
mais en même temps enfin l'argent papier
c'est un truc assez particulier tu vois
c'est une abstraction quand même assez
fort tu vois de se dire
tu peux avoir deux enfin je sais pas
comment ça marche du coup ou si
peut-être qu'à un moment tu peux avoir
des sociétés qui utilisent de l'argent
et puis après en fait c'est une chance
pour comprendre ça souvent c'est
l'échelle c'est la démographie
en fait si on utilise à ce point la
monnaie le chéquier les virements et
tout enfin c'est parce qu'on doit
organiser beaucoup beaucoup de gens une
société où il y a beaucoup d'individus
mais quand tu prends des petites
cellules des petits foyers souvent ils
l'utilisent pas enfin
après c'est tous les trucs de dons
contre don aussi de Mosses qui doivent
être le bouquin un peu à lire sur
sur le don de Marcel Moos ok c'est la
référence sur bah en fait il explique
que quand tu reçois quelque chose c'est
jamais gratuit et en fait ça génère des
de du lien tout de suite avec celui qui
t'a donné et donc souvent ça génère un
contredon qui doit être plus grand plus
massif et c'est une des explications
aussi du besoin de stocker les choses en
fait tu avais fait un épisode qui était
super intéressant avec comment les dons
et les contredons ça permettait de
construire des des édifices là de pierre
et de les menhirs enfin les dolmens
j'ai mis un peu de temps à lire ton
message parce que ça parlait beaucoup et
c'était très
pour les plantes la bouffe pour nourrir
les vaches tout ça vous allez avoir plus
d'infos dans les épisodes qui suivent
j'ai pas encore écrit en détail comment
ça marche même si j'ai une idée globale
et du coup je vais pas le révéler
maintenant
des trucs qui se passe plus tard mais
oui effectivement
s'il y a plus de lumière c'est chiant
pour 2-3 trucs mais tu comprendras plus
tard pourquoi ça marche sur la photo
synthèse les vaches et tout comment
elles rumine
je suis sûr quand il sera en train de
l'écrire et vous balancera toutes les
infos de scénario que vous voulez poser
des questions et je vous spoile venez
point d'exclamation the Willow
s'il y a des gens qui veulent venir
poser des questions tranquille
sans les joueurs
plus de chance on regardera pas
mais moi c'est le truc qui est alors que
je ne pouvais pas développer en tant que
Fredo concierge mais
le truc de voyage dans le temps du coup
ça me fait penser enfin c'est trop
intéressant parce que genre là on voit
que Fredo il meurt en 2029 alors que
nous on est là et du coup ça commence à
ouvrir le hoquet donc dans quelle
théorie de voyage temporel on est parce
que suivant l'univers c'est jamais la
même chose quoi il y en a ou dès que tu
voyages mais en fait tu crées une autre
version de l'univers il y en a ou tu
peux vraiment revenir en mode de retour
vers le futur enfin du coup j'ai hâte
aussi tu vois de
lucides
oui je sais c'est de la fiction mais
moi je ouais voilà
j'ai l'impression que voilà c'est la
théorie des cordes
ça doit être intéressant
on peut revenir aussi sur le votre petit
puzz là que vous avez pas résolu ah
ouais ok
Valentine les compétences de puzzle
pour que tu galères
en fait il manque des trucs
plus de temps
la chim
c'est de la formule qu'est-ce que tu
fais là
ok j'arrive tout de suite
c'était vraiment habile et plaisant à
faire donc merci pour ça c'était bon
moment préféré
donc une j'ai envie de dire entre gros
Guillaume et vrai et équation chimique
il y a juste bah du coup deux éléments
résultant qui n'existent pas
c'est vrai que moi du coup j'ai une
compétence inverse
équilibré
si quelqu'un veut expliquer comment ça
marche une équation chimique peut-être
que ça intéresse des gens alors là en
fait
mais je le prends pas en fait le truc
c'est que ça peut être équilibré c'est à
dire que une équation chimique en gros
c'est
un
des éléments
chimiques voilà dans certaines
conditions peuvent donner d'autres
éléments enfin d'autres molécules en
fait
et suivant les éléments ça va être de
d'un côté ou de l'autre par exemple le
faire
suivant les conditions on peut avoir
Fe2+ ou F3 plus il y a pas de faire non
mais là oui là il y a pas de fer mais
donc en gros suivant les conditions du
milieu on peut avoir la partie gauche de
l'équation ou la partie droite de
l'équation
le truc c'est que même si tu l'as
équilibré en fait il y a des
arrangements de d'atomes qui sont pas
possibles oui genre en terme de lien
c'est mort mais genre le N par exemple
[Musique]
dont je pourrais parler un petit peu
mais je me ventouse il y a un truc que
j'ai mis en rapport avec toi d'ailleurs
au début le sien CO3 là ça c'est du
calcaire
[Musique]
le calcaire c'est une roche
majoritairement constituée de quel site
ouais et du coup ça c'est de la calcite
et c'est trop bien et c'est un minéral
c'est ce qui compose effectivement le
calcaire et je vais éternuer donc je
vais te laisser enchaîner si tu veux
la quel site
c'est un des minéraux les plus communs
sur terre
et on retrouve pas mal de Betty
piquement les os
je crois qu'il y a de laquelle site
dedans c'est à dire que la je sais plus
comment s'appelle
mais en gros c'est un dérivé de laquelle
site qui compose les autres
non non sans doute je l'ai dit dans une
de mes vidéos en plus
il y en a moins mais c'était une vidéo
où j'étais allé à l'université de Nantes
et on avait rencontré un chercheur qui
travaillait justement à créer une pâte
de synthèse c'est l'apatite le minéral
voilà
exactement parce que c'est hydraté et en
fait ouais ce chercheur il travaillait à
faire
l'hydroxyète il travaille à faire une
pâte synthétique qui pouvait remplacer
l'os et qu'on pouvait injecter avec une
seringue et donc pour tout ce qui est
ostéoporose
typiquement on te change une hanche et
bah hop c'est l'occasion de faire de
l'impression 3D de
avec ton truc quoi
en fait enfin l'enjeu de ce chercheur
c'était la pâte elle existe c'était de
mettre des médicaments dans la pâte ce
qui fait que quand on te l'injecte et
ben on peut te mettre l'anti douleur en
en local dans l'os quoi de
plein de géologie avec non c'est de la
chimie de la chimie géologique c'est de
la Chine des pratiques et inorganique je
fais derrière moi
il y a le champ aussi en bas là c'est 5
h2o3n je sais pas si ça existe vraiment
ça c'est le champ en fait c'est un
raccourci qu'on utilise en notamment
biologie mais pas que je pense c'est
c'est quoi c'est les quatre éléments les
plus fins les plus hauts le feu là
du coup cette chanson hydrogène
du coup non ça existe pas ça existe pas
les deux que j'ai inventé c'est les deux
premiers qui résultent
ok mais ouais le fond ça m'a fait
plaisir de le voir ça m'a rappelé des
souvenirs
le fond mais ça c'est le chemin le chaud
carbone
hydrogène
oui pourquoi tu as mis de la capsule
[Musique]
avec
de la salive ça décolore par contre
elle est transparente elle est
birréfringente
pas été regardé de ce côté-là
non je sais plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la calcite
je sais plus il faut que tu m'aides
qu'elle était phosphorescente
j'ai dit ça oui oui j'ai dit ça
alors pas du tout
sans doute
alors
fluorescent
il renvoie oh là là je vais me faire
découvrir
avec des lumières noires dessus et tout
et ça brille genre ça reflète
exactement
oui il faudra bien fact checker parce
que j'ai jamais compris
le prochain comme la dernière fois je te
réponds je ne sais pas oui
c'est la semaine prochaine quoi c'est ça
passez au crible toutes nos affirmations
c'est ça finalement
génétique toutes les prestations
je vois pas moi j'ai hâte après de dans
le chat
quand même qui était assez évident le
truc
les deux voix un peu l'adaptation et le
les solutions techniques aux problèmes
de
reçois on reste dans la merde mais on
essaie de genre s'éclairer autrement
soit on essaie de régler le de vivre
avec donc on fait des avions hydrogène
soit on arrête les avions quoi ouais
c'est pas pareil mais c'est dans les
prochains
puis surtout je pense que là on va être
confronté vraiment à des des problèmes
des cas de figure il y a eu un choix
scientifiquement quelqu'un qui vient
avec une mallette et qui vous demande de
la transporter et qui lance sa clope
avant de venir nous voir
c'est moi je suis pas académique mais
voilà généralement je conseille la
menace c'était ouais bah vous aurez à
faire la à Lara j'étais en mode mes
frères tu vas la contacter comment en
fait genre on va y arriver avant toi
alors donc en fait bah tu sais pas il y
a peut-être un système de courrier
des pigeons
je sais pas juste des gens qui vont
d'une ville à l'autre quoi
on est parti direct
[Musique]
il y avait aucune raison qu'on prenne la
mallette quoi la phosphorescence c'est
de la physique quantique
ah oui carrément non mais ça c'est ça je
suis sûr
[Musique]
parfait
qui signe les billets
elle va bien moi j'ai rien d'autre à
dire donc sous quelqu'un vont encore
devenir sûr quelque chose que dans le
chat vous vouliez dire poser une
dernière question là avant qu'on
s'arrête où on se dit au revoir pour ça
peut être des questions cons ça peut
être des questions
j'ai juste des questions quand même sur
l'organisation un peu de truc militaire
avec les scientifiques qui font leur
truc et de leur côté enfin bon peut-être
pas on n'a pas toutes les informations
mais
ça m'a l'air louche tout s'est
financements là les Aigles rouges ça a
l'air louche bah oui merci
j'ai des petits trucs que je connais
comme ça je reconnais quand les
situations
enfin voilà
ils ont pas l'air très fun en même temps
on n'a pas essayé de faire des pets avec
nos aisselles devant eux donc si ça se
trouve
comme le truc oui
c'est un de mes talents ça ah c'est une
compétence spéciale faire la cloche faut
pas vous dire quoi
non mais non mais non
maintenant c'est pas ça
[Musique]
je me suis entraîné j'avais plus à le
faire
je me suis dit peut-être qu'en 200 ans
la tradition
non pas ça
en même temps ça pourra nous aider genre
faire gagner du temps tu vois sur une
une embrouille
[Musique]
je suis en train de penser à un truc moi
je me suis parti du principe que c'était
possible mais s'il faut on a pas le
droit ou pas en France
donc la descendance s'appelle bidon oui
comme toi en général les fils fait les
filles puis ça prend plutôt le nom du
père est-ce que c'est possible que on
dise non non on prend le nom de la mer
pas mal de société j'ai l'impression que
c'est pas vraiment le truc qui était
fait mais
bon ça quand même
oh mec
pas en Espagne je crois pas il y a pas
une histoire où tu prends forcément le
prénom du
nom
ça fait 4 semaines
d'ailleurs
je pense que
[Rires]
les cours
mon truc que j'ai dit que pendant 2000
ans les jeunes ont toujours dit que
c'était moins bien que enfin c'est
toujours fainéant et machin là je crois
que c'est assez vrai pas mal de
citations dans pas mal de de bouquins de
citations de gens vieux à chaque fois
chaque génération depuis c'est même dans
Homer ou dans des trucs comme ça
c'est intéressant quand même tu vois
c'est pénible non mais voilà tu viens
un truc de les la jeunesse écoute une
musique différente tu vois ça je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que tu as des fois
tu avais des stagnations un petit peu de
[Musique]
je rigolais
ah oui pour la vie
mon personnage
parfait
ok bon ben on va se laisser là merci
de nous avoir suivi donc n'hésitez pas à
aller checker les réseaux sociaux de
tout le monde donc il y a des commandes
dans le chat les modérateurs je vous
laisse balancer les quatre commandes là
comme ça 5 j'ai pas besoin il y a des
très belles photos sur nos réseaux
sociaux
venez voir ce que tout le monde fait et
puis on se retrouve dans deux semaines
pour l'épisode 3 du coup c'est ça ça
marche allez ciao